this is Jocko podcast number 76 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening echo good evening
freedom that's something that you hear
me talk about all the time and I say
little things like don't take it for
granted and I say be thankful for your
freedom and I even say things like you
don't appreciate your freedom until it's
gone pretty common statements you hear
from people but how many of us have
actually had our freedom taken away and
not metaphorically speaking and not some
self-imposed and thereby self controlled
way and not in some way trapped by a
situation in our life that we don't have
the courage to get out of but I am
talking about an actual loss of freedom
caged controlled starved beaten tortured
how long can you take that for an hour a
day or about a week or a month what
about a year for six years what do you
do how do you survive how do you get up
every day and face the awful reality
that you live in darkness fear
oppression
and how do you take that darkness and
that fear and that oppression and turn
it into something good
well it is my honor today to have with
us a man that can answer those questions
retired Navy captain Charles Charlie
plumb Naval Academy graduate f4 phantom
fighter pilot and prisoner of war in
North Vietnam for six years
six years sir it is an absolute honor to
have you on and thank you so much for
being here thank you jack oh it's a
pleasure to be with you
and let's just start from the beginning
okay of captain and Charlie plop you
were you I know you're born wearing I
was actually born in Gary Indiana during
World War two
my father was about to be inducted and
so he moved us to a little tiny town in
Kansas where he thought my mother and I
and my big sister could live there while
he went off to war well as it turned out
he couldn't pass a physical so he didn't
go to war but that's where I grew up in
a tiny town in the middle of Kansas and
I know you uh you did you went to work
pretty at a pretty early age throwing
papers oh yeah you referred to that in
the book and I just that's just a
nostalgic thing isn't it throwing no one
throws papers anymore it doesn't happen
there's no kids with paper roads anymore
I guess that's true I read a statistic
one time of all the of all the
successful people in the world most of
them were paper boys I have a kid but
not anymore you're right you don't you
don't see that yeah now they're throwing
up Twitter posts yeah that's it no I see
I see the Topeka daily capital in this
little town of 300 people and I had
about 55 customers the route was five
miles long
and on a cold February morning in Kansas
that was off a long way I finally
convinced my father that I could down
that I could buy a motor scooter with
all of my earnings and so we went across
the river where there was no bank in
town went across the river to Perry
Kansas and borrowed enough money to buy
a Cushman motor scooter and I was only
14 when that happened
yeah so I got arrested one night so I
good up - no yeah we're doing that you
got arrested on the motor scooter well I
was trying to go to the County Fair
because can you even speed on a motor
scooters I thought no no I like it but I
I was small from my age so at 14 I I
know I wasn't 5 feet and then had my
buddy on the back and he was even
smaller than I and I think that the cops
just thought he did look kids on a motor
scooter in the middle of night and we
were arrested and at some point I think
it was you had a basketball coach there
were coaching your school that was a
pilot in World War two he was actually
he he was a vet but not a pilot he was a
Doughboy in World War one Wow yeah and
he had shrapnel in his leg from his war
and he walked with a limp and but then
he was quite a disciplinarian and he he
tried to make that little basketball
team work but we we were just really not
not very talented what is it about I
don't know when I was a kid and I would
see an you know a Vietnam vet for me
that's primarily what I would see is old
Vietnam vets and I'd say hey that guy's
got shrapnel his leg and walks with a
limp
when I grow up I want travelin my leg I
want to walk with a limp that's my goal
that just is that just part of male boot
you know boy nature it may very well
help but he yeah so so what did he tell
you about about pilots that he's never
happy or he'll get the idea from you
know being a Doughboy to be in a pilot
well quite a long transition see this
was early on in my career now I had a
coach later in high school that had been
a pilot in World War two okay so Bill
Johnson had been a pilot in fact he flew
of f8 of aircraft carriers and I was
fascinated by that whole idea but I will
tell you that being a hayseed from
Kansas I never even dreamed of flying an
airplane I never been in one I seen them
fly over but the whole idea of ever even
riding in an air
let alone piloting one was was beyond my
grasp
it really was it's so so how did you end
up then transition from high school and
you end up in you know going to the
Naval Academy
well that was kind of by accident too I
needed an education my parents were too
poor to send me to college I started
looking for scholarships and my older
sister was dating a guy who was an in
ROTC student at the University of Kansas
and he gave me a book that says here's
how you apply for the in OTC and Kansas
well the back page of the book in fairly
small letters said oh by the way it's
the same qualifications to go to the
Naval Academy well what the heck did you
even know what the Naval Academy was
figured out right there I did not know I
I really had no idea I I didn't know
about the Army Navy game I didn't know
anything now my closest relative in the
military was a cousin in a Coast Guard
and so I was just I was just ignorant
about the military and total so you know
I like I'd like to see their Jaakko and
tell you that all these great dreams you
know of being a fighter pilot and the
Admiral and commanding ships and
squadrons and all of it and no it was
all by accident in fact I when I applied
well you know you get appointments from
congressmen the congressmen of my
district in Kansas I did it by a
competitive method and everybody was
interested took a government test you
know for a gr-18 you know a government
service rating a GS test and there were
about 35 guys that took the test and so
he nominated five of us who got better
scores on the test and the rest and then
he appointed one one guy to the Naval
Academy and an alternate and I was the
second alternate okay well the first guy
also had an appointment to to the Air
Force Academy so he took that the second
guy discovered girls
gotta leave work yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah uh so I was actually the second
alternate to go stick and so I got on
that Greyhound bus in Kansas City Kansas
and the two days later took me two days
to get to watching the DC and of course
I was seeing country I'd never seen
before and that's when I raised my hand
as you did and pledged to defend the
Constitution United States against all
enemies foreign and domestic and then at
some point at the after debut did you
know about Naval Aviation I guess you
did from from Bob Johnson yeah he told
you about naval aviation did you have
that thought in your mind of naval
aviation at that point not really I
still I still kind of assumed that I
could never qualify to do that you know
and and in thinking back at it you know
I think well where were my dreams but
kids that grow up in little towns don't
usually have big dreams we don't know
how to do that and my parents my father
had completed the eighth grade that was
his education my mother had in fact
completed high school but I was one of
the first in the family to ever go to
college and so you know was it I it
wasn't even it wasn't even a thought
part of the thought process so once I
got to the Naval Academy and you know
thought back to Bob Johnson and that
kind of experience and saw that there
was a possibility of doing this then my
energies and efforts turn turned towards
Naval Aviation and it must have been
thats always been ultra competitive at
the academy and i know we had another
pilot on Dave Burke and he was talking
about how each step of the way he kind
of looked around and and said I think I
can actually do this you know it's kind
of the same thing you look around and
say I think I can get the best grades I
think I can get in this position at some
point you must have said if I can I
think I can do this there was as a
matter of fact it is a great revelation
you know when it completely finally
talked to yourself into accepting the
fact that you do have the talent to do
this and until that point the
you don't really try as hard I guess and
while you're at the Academy also you is
this when you got involved with em for
the first time is that at the at the
Naval Academy and was my high school
sweetheart okay yeah we played the
French horn in the band together that's
girls at the French horn yeah yeah yeah
yeah if she was she is a beauty and was
a beauty and she showed up at our school
but was she she came cheap she came into
Arnold town in Kansas from Indiana and
she had a boyfriend in Indiana and she
wasn't telling me about you know for the
first several don't care about that
boyfriend no his name is Bart and I
called him Black Bart
so Bart was um and and she wouldn't kiss
me you know I mean we dated for months
as the girl wouldn't kiss me yeah ding
you know just stuff I mean I mean it's
the most reaction ever segata exercise I
think he's been there has heard of just
the bad memories on my heart maybe we
should talk about your story oh god the
kissing denial so finally I think it was
Thanksgiving yeah yeah it was it was
right at Thanksgiving him and i
intercepted a letter that she'd gotten
from Bart and how do you intercept a
letter I was not very mature no it was
all aboveboard but a so I will leave it
at that I guess I just were going to
leave now what is it okay I can find it
her you know when I Bart oh no it's a no
we're serious we're going to get married
someday
in fact he's coming to Kansas for
Christmas I said I'll make a deal with
you I said I don't think he's coming for
Christmas and so if he comes I'll back
off and you don't have to worry about me
trying to kiss you anymore
but if he doesn't come then you and I go
steady well he didn't come and so I that
started a wonderful relationship we then
went steady in high school of course
then I go off to the Naval Academy
herpes from Kansas and and she went to
the University of Kansas for her first
year there and but we continued to
communicate and and I just well I saw
heard Christmastime when I came home and
then she decided to move to Washington
DC to work for a senator out there and
so she spent the next three years the
last three years as naval academy
they're close enough so that we going to
continue to see each other so it was um
when I was one of those you know one and
only kind of a thing because I didn't
really date a whole lot in high school
and she was it for sure so then you guys
got married you did you wait to
graduated from the Naval Academy yet oh
yeah you know you can't you can't get
married while you're at the Naval
Academy at least you're not supposed to
a couple guys did and I didn't and so
the day after I graduated from the Naval
Academy
we were we were married and my six buddy
is held up their swords well one was a
Marine and so he held up his saber as we
came down from the chapel through the
arch of swords and it was a beautiful
day and a beautiful wedding and from
there we went immediately to flight
training did you see when did you find
out you were going to pick up a flight
trainer our senior so yeah the last last
part of our senior year you can apply
and and then you go through all of the
hoops that you go through to try to
qualify for Naval Aviation speeding so I
found out probably a month or six weeks
before I graduated that was going to be
my night or do you graduate in 64 yes so
when you graduated
did you guys were you guys thinking
Vietnam already none was it just too
early and there was limited operation so
it wasn't really something that you guys
were thinking about
front of mind I don't remember ever
hearing the word Vietnam while I was
just a Naval Academy Wow yeah so you
rolled to flight school just thinking
hey we're going to fly around we're
going to go do regular deployments which
you'd heard about but you weren't
thinking about Vietnam yep so at what
point was that in flight school when you
first started think of yourself hey we
got guys over here dropping bombs
yeah well Everett Alvarez was shot down
the the first day oh they better be shot
down in August 1964 okay so it became a
reality that while I was in flight
training and I'm another naval aviator
was in prison in Vietnam now I didn't
you know I didn't understand the
politics I didn't question the politics
of it at all I just did the best I could
in flight training and and enjoyed it
you know I mean it's it's a kick did you
guys did hear did your attitudes shift
and also for my generation when all of a
sudden September 11th happened it was
like it was like a paradigm shift in
everyone's mentality that that day it
was such a clear clear demonstration and
we all knew that we were going to war
and that was an immediate attitude shift
did you guys start to have a shift in
attitude or was it so because the way
Vietnam escalated more slowly was it
more of a slow escalation in your minds
as well no it was very slow you know his
story of the frog in the in the pot of
boiling water you know jumps out an area
but but no it was it just warmed up very
slowly for us and I didn't even as I
went to fight training you know I mean I
learned to drop bombs and shoot guns and
all that stuff and it was it was a
challenging and it was exciting but I I
didn't see the reality of it I didn't
really picture myself as being in combat
so of course when I got my wings and
then was assigned the f4 phantom which
at the time was the hottest airplane in
the world I'm we had the time to climb
records and the speed records and so
it's a twice a speed of sound airplane
and it was felt very fortunate to to
have been assigned that airplane
so I came out here to San Diego to to
fly and you talked about your book
you've done a Midshipmen tour where a
phantom went down both pilots killed and
and then you got a sign of the Phantom I
did that give you any reservations at
all I don't remember being afraid of the
airplane but I certainly gave it a lot
of respect especially around the ship
because that's you know I saw this thing
go down at the Naval Academy in the
summertime you get exposed to the
possible billets you might have in the
future so we go play marine for a while
and we go to submarines for a while and
we go aboard ships it to be line
officers for a while and we go to to
Pensacola and so I got a little touch of
it there of actually being in airplanes
and then my senior my senior cruise
between my junior and senior year I'm
going to board the the constellation the
aircraft carrier constellation and and
we were out of Sasebo Japan
and I'm watching flight ops from the
bridge and you know I'm looking down at
this the airplanes
launching and recovering on this
aircraft carrier and a phantom came in
she actually broke the wire the pilot
did okay but he broke he picked up the
wire and the wire snapped this cable
that traps an airplane is two and a half
inches in in diameter it's a very thick
steel wire around cable arm is really
really strong because it has to stop
this thirty five thousand pound airplane
going down the chute at 170 miles an
hour so but for whatever reason the
cable broke okay the cable snapped
around and it cut off the legs of three
different guys who are on the deck okay
it was so fast that I couldn't even even
see it my eyes couldn't even follow this
cable because there was just tell me
there's so much pressure as so much
energy involved and then the airplane
the f4 was slowed down to the point
where the guy couldn't get back in the
air
and so it just dribbled off the bow of
the aircraft carrier into the water well
of course then I then I turn my view to
the stern of the ship to see if I could
see what had happened one of the few
seconds that it took from when it
settled in the water until I could see
out the the back of the ship it was gone
there was no debris there was no oil
there was nothing in the water behind
this ship that this airplane had gone
down so it was a shock to me of course
but you know I think I started out with
this mentality that is always going to
happen to somebody else you know never
me and in that I'm you know I'm whatever
happened I'm going to do it better and
and I think that's well you know this
better than I you have to kind of have
that mentality in combat you can't go in
thinking you're going to get killed
and so so I I wasn't reluctant to fly
the f4 but I gave it I think respect so
you get that and you come out here
stationed in San Diego that was outside
San Diego right for when you when you
deployed for the first time Miramar
Naval Air Station know and that's where
I helped start Top Gun that was kind of
an interesting experience as well there
was a there was a pool of students to
fly the f4 phantom and I showed up here
when they had about a six-month waiting
list for me to fly this airplane well
six month was a long time you know for a
23 year old kid and I wanted to get in
the air so a buddy of mine Paul kruky
and I had gotten our wings at the same
time and been assigned the f4 phantom we
came out here and so we were both going
to have to wait for six months to fly
this airplane so we wandered down the
flight line at Miramar and found the
instrument training squadron was flying
the same airplanes that we had flown in
in flight training the old f9 cougar a
bent wing airplane it's um it's a jet
but it's light and slow and kind of
studies it's a
Kurian weapon and and they were they
were using it in flight training to
teach instruments and the way they do
this the instructor would sit in the
front seat and this didn't sit in the
back seat and they had a bag that that
covered all the windows kind of covered
you up all you could see was the
instrument panel here under this bag and
so and so we signed on to fly this
airplane for test hops and check rides
and this kind of stuff just to fly just
stay in the air because we were already
qualified the airplane well
kruky and i would save a little bit of
gas okay each time we'd fly these
students around at the end of the hop we
would lurk off the the coast of San
Diego and wait for the Phantom's to come
out and so we you know we these guys
would come up and run away at Miramar
and they were heavy you know and they
were stodgy and they were slow as they
came off and they'd get about four or
five miles out in the Pacific and we
would pounce on these guys and it was
all kinds of fun because we were lighter
and could turn quicker than the
Phantom's you know we were a smaller we
had a better wing load than they did and
so we could turn inside these guys of
course they were much much faster we
were not supersonic and they were so
they could get away from us and in a
heartbeat if they wanted to but we
started this air combat maneuvering with
these guys well that went on for I don't
know a couple of months until one day
kruky and I I mean we played the role we
had white scarves you know Snoopy
goggles and all works and one thing we
came back and to the instrument squadron
and checked in our airplanes back in and
it was signed on the bulletin board Plum
Creek II report to the f4 commanding
officer immediately we were in trouble
so due to two guys in their sweaty
flight suits knock on the door of a
commanding officer of the Phantom
squadron I'll never forget this scene
the guy come in
we open the dorm that this guy sent to
the long desk okay and and and he's got
glasses and of course he's an old old
guy we were 23 so you know he was
probably 30 but you know this guy you've
ever taught older guys yeah and so he's
sitting there talked over the top of his
glasses he's in a sweaty flight suit
also which should have been our first
indication is that you two guys out
there in the f9s hasslein my fighter
pilots yes sir we were did you follow a
phantom through an entire loop w yeah
yes sir in fact we did so did you have
your gun sights on that phantom the
entire time yes yes sir we did he said
do you know who was in that phantom he
said I was is that I just came back from
Vietnam our kill ratio over there is
terrible they're eating our lunch we
need to learn how to fight this airplane
see the f4 was designed during the Cold
War as a supersonic interceptor I was
never called a fighter pilot in fact I
trained in a spacesuit so I could go
above fifty thousand feet you know off
the aircraft carrier climb to 80
thousand feet shoot down the Russian
bombers and you know 45-degree angle of
Bank turn return of the aircraft carrier
that was my job I wasn't supposed to be
out there hassling because because it
was a cold war we did not expect to have
a Korean War World War two type of a
soul and the fighter pilot well of
course Vietnam came around and suddenly
you know they're they're flying these
older airplanes that were eating our
lunch so be the CEO looked at us and he
said you want to you want to fight with
me tomorrow oh yes sir that's fun so for
the next two or three months Paul kruky
and I with our white scarves and our
Snoopy goggles we get 9/11 we had to
start about an hour ahead of time you
know just because they were so fast but
we'd get out to sea we go out to 40
miles out to sea and turn around and
here they come and we'd had these two on
two engagements
and and that became a syllabus within
the replacement air group of the f-4s
that eventually became the top gun
school that's awesome yeah it was it was
the start of retraining well and it was
it was very successful we turned our
kill ratio around by teaching pilots how
to fight this f4 phantom yeah maybe
clearly that's it without training to
fight how are you going to know how to
fight all right and you got a you got a
beat that's outstanding for the for the
commanding officer that squadron says I
want instead of being instead of being
mad that you were doing it instead he's
humble and says you know what we need to
get better at this yeah let's let's
let's keep training yep that's awesome
and you eventually do get your time in
the f4 phantom you learn how to fly that
and now it's time to go on deployment
you're going on deployment now November
5th 1966 you kiss and goodbye you go on
deployment on the on the Kitty Hawk it
was her birthday oh that's a great
birthday present very nice of you my
first daughter my first daughter was
born actual birthday like actual
birthday yeah I went on deployment the
next day so everyone was really happy
with me on that one when now when you
were going through the flight training
you were getting ready to deployed now
were you thinking about via nominal I
mean you must have been getting feedback
from you got female commanding officer
so now focus it shifted something up it
certainly had and the squadron that I
joined was just coming back from Vietnam
and they'd had quite a few casualties
and and so they were talking about you
know the guys were the guys were were
giving us instruction on how to work
that another thing about the phantom was
that we had we had no indication when a
missile was in the air because we were
faster than the missile for the most
part are higher than the missile and so
one of the things the guys the guys told
me the fellows coming back from Vietnam
said go down to Radio Shack buy yourself
a fuzz buster you know I like her like
police detective you know yeah the old
fuzz Atari out he said because the
russian-built sam surface-to-air miss
are on the same frequency as a
California Highway Patrol truth - sorry
and so we have found that if you because
we have no indication in the airplane
when it missiles in the interim and so I
did it
not a regular jack by myself a buzz bus
trip and it had little suction cup moon
you lift the suction cup and you put it
on the windscreen and this this kahneman
and remember white wire you know down
underneath your g-suit and your sort
cultural harness and under your oxygen
mask and and finally into your ear you
know you get just here so here bud in
there II and so here I am flying this 20
million-dollar airplane being protected
by $29 five bucks it worked but the
problem was there was no direction
capability couldn't tell where it was
coming from and so you know that's
almost worse like wait you know cycle I
was like oh man absolutely you heard the
horrible and boy you know you said it
turn and jink and you know your head
went on a swivel trying to figure out
where this this missile is you but you
get overseas and you're flying you start
flying missions you're doing we're doing
mostly strike missions is that primarily
what you're even taking out targets in
North Vietnam the f4 of course again was
considered was configured and built from
the keel up as a as an air-to-air combat
machine right the powers that be decided
eight there's an airplane we can hang a
bomb on it they put on an extra I
believe four hard points on the bottom
of this airplane maybe five can't
remember so that we could carry bombs on
this fighter airplane well we were
supposed to be interceptors we weren't
supposed to be carrying bombs around but
we found out that sure enough this big
old airplane was a pretty good platform
for dropping bombs and so we could carry
you know we could carry twelve thirteen
thousand pounds of bombs into the target
which was a pretty good load you know we
could also support you know guys like
you on the ground that
uh with all kinds of various kinds of
weaponry and so what happened was we had
a sister squadron on the aircraft
carrier so for a month line period we
would be fighters for two weeks and then
we would we would we would reconfigure
our airplane to be bombers and would be
bombers for two weeks and we would go
back to fighters and then back to
bombers being so to answer your question
half the time over there I was dropping
bombs and half the time I was I was
doing the air-to-air mission and the
air-to-air mission primarily be doing
combat air patrols to support the other
elements that will find in with bombs
and you'd be protecting in case any make
showed up exactly it was a CA P a cap
combat air patrol so you're pretty much
almost done with deployment we're
talking you you spend you did what 74
missions at this point you've been there
for fiber coming up on six months and on
the 19th of May 1967 you get a phone
call and you guys get like a strike
mission comes in that you are supposed
to execute it was a big deal and it was
called an alpha strike an alpha strike
was the top priority and we needed it
would be a lot of airplanes in the air
and we have some pretty important
targets to hit and it was sanctioned
straight from the Pentagon it was JC s
stuff and which of course is one of the
problems in that war was that most of
our instruction came from the guys back
in the puzzle palace and you know they
wouldn't they wouldn't let us decide
targets or altitudes or anything else it
was pretty well well planned by the time
we got to go and I got a call and I
suppose 3:00 in the morning something
like that saying that I was to schedule
this flight I was a schedules officer
for the prop for the squadron and so I
was a guy that figured out who went on
what strikes and who went with whom and
in the airplanes at the head so so I got
up early to start play
any in this strike with the airplanes
and the pilots and the the back Cedars
our radar intercept officer Zarko pilots
and and so I did then we went to the
briefing room and got about an hour
briefed on this these targets I Lena
found out that the reason for the whole
thing the reason why we were doing an
office strike on the 19th of May was it
was the birthday of their president Ho
Chi Minh and again in Redemption many
exactly the brilliance of you know of
our side our sy war great was that we
would text them in celebration of their
of the big day because they it was like
our president today you know they had
picnics and that kind of stuff so we
were going to catch him with a pants
down well as most things that happen in
Vietnam they knew we were coming for
whatever reason and that day there were
eight f4 phantoms shot down but I'll
never forget the beginning of it because
you know I took off and that rendezvous
with the tanker and took on an extra
three thousand pounds of fuel and then
joined the squadron and it was in fact
cap mission it was a combat air patrol I
was not carrying bombs so we had four of
us on one side of the strike group and
four of the other and just to look
because it was three our craft carriers
and five air force bases all just
throwing everything we had at the enemy
that day it was amazing Armada and I
could see from one horizon to the other
these airplanes and and I remember
feeling really proud you know and you
know just to be a part of this doing
something that very few people in the
world would ever do and flying this
airplane at age 24 and so that that was
how it all began on the 19th of May and
one of the things that we were talking
about before we we hit record was the
kind of the sense of humor that you have
in the military and and what that's like
and I one of the by the way haven't even
mentioned that referring to a book that
you wrote called I'm no hero by Charlie
plum and that'll be that's available on
Amazon get it too and be a link on the
website but also a book could actually
been around my website because I sign
everyone that that goes down so my
website Charlie plum calm okay well
there you go even better going to the
book here you guys are getting before
you launch you're getting ready to
launch kind of getting ready for the
briefing and here we go the pilots of
the fighter planes gathered in their own
briefing room and read from a television
screen and teletype the weather
information and the position of the ship
we reviewed once again the switches we
would have to throw and I coordinated
with the maintenance officer the weapons
we would need the volume of the fuel etc
serious thoughts were in the back of all
our minds but outwardly our mood was
light we laughed and joked drank coffee
and smoked my regular Rio which is the
radar intercept officer does a
backseater because the the f4 phantom
has two people was up to his old habit
of manipulating his slide rule being a
self-styled math wizard he again
pinpointed his likelihood of getting
bagged shot down this was based on some
speculative formula he had found
somewhere today friends he proclaimed my
bag factor is point zero one nine three
seven six and then you applied to him
then saved me a room at the Hanoi Hilton
again I'm glad you're still laughing
about that the rest of you as we go
through this book will see the true
irony of that joke you know back to the
book here we left our ready room and
entered the central briefing room where
all the pilots Rios and standby crew
scrutinized their master plan which
included maps and photographs the
targets and intelligence sports of
enemies fire capability after our
central briefing we return to our ready
room meditated last minute instructions
and put on our flight gear altogether
these briefings took as long and
sometimes longer than the mesh
self I looked up at the screen pilots
man your aircraft we gave each other
we stopped each other on the back
exchange of customary give them hell
dialogue and patted the posterior of our
good luck girl hanging on the door it
was time to go topside you guys are now
getting ready to take off and again just
some of this this humor back to the book
engine run-up is good takeoff checklist
is complete I'm ready to go Gary you
ready
yeah I'm ready okay i mocked this is
your captain speaking
welcome to flight 403 to Hanoi North
Vietnam we'll be flying an altitude of
11 grand and we have a high ceiling make
sure your seat belt is fastened no
smoking please so that's the attitude
going out and legitimately yours this is
your 75th mission you've flown 74 you're
feeling pretty comfortable I mean even
though of course you've got faults in
the back you mind but you feeling pretty
comfortable about how you do your job
and what you get done I am feeling
bulletproof I wasn't going to go that
far but let's just go there I know that
feeling too huh yeah yeah we as you push
in back to the book all this
coordination so it's what you just
talked about this massive effort going
forward dozens and dozens of aircraft
all of this coordination of men and
machinery during the refueling was done
in complete silence we call the zip lip
although enemy radar would have already
detected us we were careful not to give
radio spooks any additional information
it was gratifying to experience such
close rapport with my Air Wing I knew
and they knew what each was doing in
this intricate maneuver yet not a word
had to be spoken and that's I've
actually talked about that on here when
we would train and when I was running
training for the seals I would tell them
hey you're not allowed to talk during
this training I can't say one word to
each other and it was amazing after you
do that a couple times how much better
people get because they're reading
they're reacting they're anticipating
what other people are going to do and
you guys are just so far ahead at this
point five and a half months in the
deployment it's you guys are doing this
whole thing without
saying work to each other it was amazing
yeah I think that's one of the more
incredible things about the military is
even though you're just a little piece
of that big machine this big powerful
machine it's it's it's pretty awesome to
experience when you when that stuff's
going on and you kind of talked about
what what you were doing you were
positioned on the flanks anticipating
Mick how often you guys seemed eggs over
there not not often I had seen MiG's
probably four or five times up to that
point and so they they really were they
were they were really good about not
showing up until they knew the ticket to
kill something you know of course they
were they had the advantage they had the
home-field advantage and so they could
wait on their bases until we came to
them and then they would launch so if
you didn't get close to a MIG pace you
probably weren't going to see one they
were they had a very short-range ISM and
and they didn't stay in the air very
long and so we didn't see them very
often and on this one you get a call
don't you hear didn't they give you a
call for this MiG's what if it makes
20/20 west's and you start to get a
little gressive start reading out that
way a little bit
yep yep and the end this will be a
flight commander tightened you up and
said eight plumb get back over in
formation yeah well you know uh my my
best buddy there denny wisely had
already shot down two airplanes by that
time and shot had another one after I
was shot down and so he it and you know
I mean that's what every fighter pilot
wants to you know to have a MIG to his
credit and I saw this opportunity you
know five days to go this is this is my
this is my day this is Charlie fun day
so I started ease out of squadron so
that I would be the first to go after
this MIG and Charlie plums are going to
get his
laughter but now that that that's how it
began and they tightened you back up so
you fall back into formation and now
there's a saint if ever Sam call did you
pick it up on the phones buster
I did but there were a lot of them in
the air and and and and so that thing
was warbling all the time there were
they were they were salvo in there
Sam's that day they just they just shoot
a bunch of them off at the same time and
so every time they shot went off and
every time their radar would scan me I
would get to fuzz Buster but we also had
you know we had the the big radar
airplanes in the sky at the same time
and and and they would call us and and
that's how I got that call that twenty
mile away call was was was from more
like electronic folks that were flying
well above us with the radar so you know
that there's Sam surface-to-air missiles
up there and here we go back to the book
Gary this year that's your real sitting
behind you in the plane I said Gary do
you see it he says I don't see a thing
Charlie we had both seen Sam's before
they resembled flying light telephone
poles with huge fourth of July sparklers
spring silvery orange glows from their
tails if we saw them in time we could
dodge the missiles by letting them close
in at the last second pulling the plane
into a high G barrel roll six GS or so
and letting the poles pass harmlessly
underneath because of its design the
missile could not follow us without
cracking into but we didn't see it
boom I felt a thump in the on panache
the after section of the airplane
airplane red instrument lights jumped
across the panel indicating that I had
two engines on fire that wasn't good
this plane only had two engines I yanked
the throttles back to idle and the bird
seemed to come to an immediate halt in
midair Charlie were hit how bad is it
she's still flying then the aircraft
started to roll
and while I'm at we scanned the
instruments I looked up and found that
the f4 it suddenly overturned ground was
where there was where there should have
been sky and the nose was heading
downward ripping air at five hundred
knobs the altimeter needle collapsed to
four thousand then 3,500 then three
thousand we had to get out but being
inverted we would be rocketed by the
ejection seat right into the rice
paddies I had to roll the plane upright
I tried to stick it was frozen
the only manual control was a rudder
pedal not normally used to roll an
aircraft I stepped on it as hard as I
could
adrenaline surging through my veins the
plane shuddered once and again slowly it
began to write itself rearview mirrors
reflected a screaming fireball 12,000
pounds of flaming gasoline and 30,000
pounds of fissionable aircrafts you want
to eject no wait a minute I shouted back
the plane struggled then the sky was
where it should be Gary let's go I
jerked my face curtain to eject the
rocket slammed me out of the aircraft I
tumbled a couple times and the chute
caught just as advertised all kinds of
debris filled the air around me as
wadding from the shells whistled by son
of a gun they bagged my airplane now
they're after me I went to the
concussions from the exploding shells
sonic booms battering my eardrums
rockets of heavy smoke clouded the sky
gary and i had adjusted ejected so near
the ground however that enemy guns could
train on us for only a short time I
checked my parachute canopy it looked
good torn in only a couple of places
I thought of escape but we're looking
away I saw my buddies and their aircraft
blending into the horizon below my
landing zone was nothing but barren rice
paddies
down to my left a huge cloud of black
smoke billowed at the outskirts of a
peasant hamlet punctuating a row of four
or five huts my plane had it wiped out a
family
if so the villagers would certainly be
unhappy I wasn't happy either I hadn't
intended that to happen I later learned
that the plan the plane had impacted
just beyond the last Shack on the road
there's precious little time before I
could touch down before I would touch
down and I had much to be done
I grabbed my two-way radio and tried to
contact Gary but I received no answer
then I called my skipper Linfield lead
Linfield lead this is lynn field - we've
got two good shoots we're going to be
alright request no SAR Evert it's Aras
search and rescue for those either don't
know and I when I read that part right
there I stopped in my tracks because
here you are you're shot down
you're in a parachute you're going to
obviously be landing in these rice
paddies surrounded by enemy and you had
the wherewithal to understand that if
you requested for search and rescue to
come and get you
it was just going to get more people
killed yeah and that had happened before
I've seen I had seen that happen in the
end we were so far behind enemy lines
and it was impossible a Jolly Green was
the thing was a call sign for the
helicopter that would come get us off
the aircraft carrier and they would have
to go through probably 75 or 100 miles
of enemy territory before they ever got
to me and and I was in such a populated
area that I could see that they were I
was going to be captured immediately and
so to get those guys to put them in
harm's way was was kind of silly so
that's why I did that
when you know I've experienced a couple
times in combat where things slow down
and the time starts to to really be
different than it normally is and they
say it's because you get this big
adrenaline dump and all of your sensors
or your your perception awakens to such
a high point that things actually slowed
down did you
experiencing that when you were once
that Sam missile hit I did yes it was
almost like slow motion and I you know I
remember thinking this is unreal I I've
never had this happen to me before but
it was almost like I was in a it was in
a movie and everything was slowing down
in my life and and I you know I tried to
sense every possible thing because of
course I'm thinking escape now trying to
get get out of here in some way and so
I'm trying to memorize all the little
roads I could see in all the little
trees not a little Hudson where are they
and where am i that situational
awareness how far from the water ocean
were you at all I was 75 miles with no
chance about no chance we won the
outskirts of Hanoi the capital city and
and and that was the bad news good news
the bad news was that I was going to be
captured immediately there was no chance
whatsoever I mean they were shooting at
me from the ground all I came down the
good news was I didn't have to go very
far to that to a formalised prison camp
like a lot of the guys did you know you
had bill reader on this on your podcast
and he was dragged for I don't know
weeks and because he was he was captured
in South Vietnam the guys were it allows
for Cambodia who were brought to our
prison camps were all just really torn
up not just because of the enemy but
just because of the rigors of the travel
so and you're going to you're going to
talk about this you talk about in the
book but you know just to kind of point
out the fact that whatever two minutes
earlier you were part of this giant
powerful force with a multi-million
dollar you know aircraft under your
command as a 24 year old as part of this
group that of many many multi-million
dollar with this huge destructive power
launching off of these ships and an
airfield and to go from having all that
to now you're under a parachute
you're about to have all of that just
absolutely taken away it was a major
transition in my life but I you know
unlike unlike someone who's diagnosed
with cancer right or unlike someone who
who just lost a job or just lots of
child orgs had a car accident I mean
that's you know that there are
similarities in normal civilian life I
think that can be just as impactive as
being blown out of the sky you're
floating down to earth and I'm going
back to the book then I bowed my head
well Lord Here I am I'm really in a bind
now and I need some help give me
strength and give and strength I was
surprised at how calm I was when I
should have been panic-stricken but
there was too much to think about and do
I couldn't let myself become irrational
it would all be different now I tried to
envision myself in this new world and
prepare for it I had a lot going for me
I was in good physical condition and I
could probably withstand torture I
didn't believe I would be killed because
I was too much of a blue chip for the
enemy which again for you to say you're
shot down you're about to land in enemy
territory and your statement is I had a
lot going for me a positive attitude sir
it's a foggy day that's your philosophy
is saying good as my notes right there I
wrote this before so you touched down I
plunged backward into the mud and water
trying to get my bearings I took off my
helmet mask and crawled out crawled
without direction in the quagmire slimy
hands I tried to wipe mud from my eyes I
saw that I was about 10 or 15 yards from
an embankment I looked over to see that
Gary touching down an adjacent patty
about 100 yards away had disappeared
behind the 8 foot embankment a barefoot
peasant wearing khaki shirts shorts and
t-shirt ran a top speed down the path
toward me grimacing with excitement and
anger above
head he waved a double-edge two acts
with blades about eight inches long my
instructors never documented that type
of weapon I heard him scream hand up
hand up I didn't understand what he
meant and I kept working with my gear
and shoot I had a 38 revolver strapped
to my chest and it and as long as he
stayed in the embankment I would not
touch it
it wasn't long however before 10 or 12
more peasants came rushing toward me
yelling and waving their shovels and
hoes now there was power in numbers and
they charged out in the water after me I
raised my hands away from my body they
started ripping my g-suit found my
survival knife and proceeded to cut away
at the suit and the torso harness I
tried to tell them to use the zippers
and even attempted to show them how to
do it but they knocked my hands away the
more certain they were that I was
harmless the meaner they became the
shovel and hoe blades flailed up my body
to prove to me that I was their Lowe's
captain captive strangely the peasant
failed to see my revolver probably
because it too was covered with mud and
the 38 rested in my holster at least
three or four minutes before peasant
finally spotted it he yanked it out of
the holster and sloshed a few steps away
a moment later he returned and screamed
for special attention he fixed the
barrel to my head I could see that at
least two of the chambers were empty
I had always kept five of the six
chambers loaded so I knew that he must
have removed at least one of the
cartridges
there was little I could do as I felt
the muddy barrel against my temple the
peasant pulled the trigger click he
could fought and sneaked away wiping off
his unexpected prize
year as far as your thoughts about being
killed at that moment did you accept
them did you were used to thinking he's
not going to do it what's your attitude
at that point I never in the entire
experience and never thought I was going
to be killed
and I didn't think think so at that
moment of course I was very happy when I
heard the click of that revolver but but
it was actually very encouraging to
think that they were going to feign this
execution and not go through with it
right and it was encouraging to me to
think that yeah they were going to
hammer me around and get me pretty
bloody but they probably weren't
intentionally going to kill me I guess I
worried more about that they would kill
me accidentally then intentionally but
and there were two or three times during
the entire experience one of them as
well as being tortured how when I felt
like I was losing it and I was close to
death and they they loosened the ropes
because they saw I think that I was
getting pretty close to death and so and
that you know again that was good
because I thought all right this is it
hurts a lot but it looks like they're
not going to kill me I may wish I was
dead but I don't think they're going to
do it now you guys are blindfolded they
captured Gary as well and you're
blindfolded but at this point they put
this kind of marginal blindfold on you
that's not working really well so you
can actually see and again I'm going to
go to your go ahead and highlight your
twisted sense of humor here so here we
go you're in the back of an old Russian
Jesus back to the book gary was held
captive in the Jeep a head of mine at
the instant I recognized Gary I started
calling hysterically for a doctor to
attend to his burned arms
the guards restrained me violently
screaming foreign but distinct
warnings to attempt no more
communications I did however shout one
more thing
I don't know why unless it was for
morale I shouted out these people are a
thousand years behind in blindfolds it
says later the POWs who were nearby
cells heard heard you screaming that and
still laughed about it
so I'm glad you kept your sense of humor
you know sometimes I look back on that
and thinking I that I was in some form
of shock maybe because I mean who would
that be who would come up with that
because it was good right this guy and
they they bring you in it from kind of
parade you guys around and you hear
cameras clicking and eventually you get
put into new guy village and you get put
into you know a torture basically a
torture room so here we go back to the
book several torture cells in the prison
the green knobby room so called because
the walls and ceiling were covered with
gobs of plaster the size of golf balls
which looked somewhat like mud dauber
nests the globs had a particular
function acoustics to muffle human sound
now you get through this day sunset I
had difficulty in seeing what was beyond
myself so I began reminiscing about the
world of active life I had loved so much
outside my every minute had been filled
outside I had been king the skies
outside I had been continually learning
doing accomplishing I had been proud so
very proud and now I was tired so tired
so perplexed so confined so very lonely
the trauma of overwhelming change caused
my mind to wheel with disorientation I
was afraid I stared at the emptiness
shadows crept up the walls gradually
becoming more pronounced
curiously a vague ghost-like impression
materialized the image took the
appearance of the master with arms
outstretched a symbol they were strange
yet something I felt I should expect I
began to utter the first lines of the
23rd psalm the Lord is my shepherd I
shall not want he maketh me to lie down
in green pastures he leadeth me beside
the still waters he restoreth my soul he
leadeth me in the paths of righteousness
for his name's sake I repeated it aloud
several times not because of any deep
religious drive but because it simply
seemed the thing to do and then I prayed
I considered making a deal with God but
rejected the idea
I made no big promises and asked for no
miracles just strength strength to
endure the hardship and strength for my
wife and it would be difficult for her
to nay though I walk through the valley
of the shadow of death that was
certainly where I was
an interesting point here is that in
Colonel readers podcast he found the
same thing that he went to the 23rd
psalm and and again it was just almost
like well this is what I should do yeah
well I say there's no atheists in
foxholes and I guess there aren't any in
the prison camp although you do talk
about some atheists in the prison camp I
do as a matter of fact come a couple of
guys to consider themselves atheist and
you know any other you also talk about
faith and one of the things that I am
glad we'll get to this but when you talk
about faith you're you talk about faith
not just in God but faith in your
country and all the one that I think
that regardless of what someone's
religious beliefs are faith in yourself
absolute and I think all three of those
or whichever one of those faiths where
you find strength it was I'm like this
lien on it absolutely and and you know
faith in the team as well and we had to
have faith in each other and then that
was awfully important to be a part of a
group like that that could trust one
another how quickly did you realize that
there was that you a part of back as
we'll get to it but I mean when you
first got here in this room did you feel
completely isolated at first and there's
no one else here no no I needed to other
presence there I could hear them you
know some of them were being tortured as
I was I could hear the torture I could
um you know I could peek out sometimes
and see them walking by myself so I knew
there were other prisoners in the area
they just wouldn't let me they wouldn't
let me talk to them so the interrogation
begins the torture begins we're going
back to the book we read copy
regulations you obey you live no trouble
okay
I did not respond first regulation you
answer all questions the way that the
North Vietnamese justified torture was
peculiar when they asked me questions
and wanted military answers
I was not tortured to answer questions
but punished for disobeying camp
regulations what what airplane you fly
I'm sorry I can't tell you Lam and they
were calling you Lam what airplane to
answer this question was of course not
in my rules I'm sorry I can't answer
that
the officer again reminded me about the
punishment for disobeying camp rules
okay you talked me or you talked steel
to which you responded bring it on the
two higher ranking officials left the
remaining officer with one word ordered
the guards for work they brought it on
the steel mentioned by the interrogator
consisted of iron manacles shackles and
a leg bar the shackles were cylindrical
iron bars shaped like horseshoes but
rounded at the end so that the five foot
leg bar could be slipped into them and
locked prisoners ankles could then be
forced through the openings and secured
by the bar
the junior officer walked out guards
blindfolded me forced my wrist behind my
back and placed the open jaws the
manacles around them these had obviously
been intended for the more modest
Vietnamese arms they were so small that
they had to be forced together just so
the screw could be seated in the bottom
of the threads with what looked like a
roller skate key a guard began to turn
the screw my skin was pinched between
the metal and quickly succumbed to the
vise I screamed in agony surely the
guards wouldn't get these things much
tighter
blood ooze down my hands and still the
guard kept turning the key like powerful
magnets the iron was finally set flush
circulation stopped my hands burned
grayish-blue tingled and became numb a
guard then wrapped the rope first around
my left elbow and then around my right
and drew my elbows together behind my
back my shoulder muscles writhed and I
feared that my sternum would separate I
gasp for air then I was thrown abruptly
to the floor shackles were jammed around
my ankles and the leg bar was fastened
and pad locked electric wire similar to
the kind that I had hidden underneath
the table was brought forward I thought
that the guards were going to use this
to shock me but typical of the
Vietnamese they didn't have anything
else to use for rope and had torn the
wire down from some light fixtures this
became the apparatus to wrap me up there
was first tied to the manacles then
thrown over my shoulder and at last
secured to the shackles around my ankles
guards forced a bamboo pole under the
wire and started rotating it so that the
wire contracted bringing my wrists up
high on my back and drawing my face
completely to my ankles I was a human
pretzel a teacup with arms for a handle
and the rest of my distorted body for
the bowl circulation was impaired
throughout my limbs making them
extremely painful to the touch the
guards apparently drugged exhibited wide
and glassy eyes they maliciously kicked
me in the sides the limbs but back and
the head giggling and having a great
time it picked me up a few feet from the
floor dropped me since I was on my side
most of the time they especially enjoyed
standing on my head symbolically
victorious the rubber tires sandals tour
of my ear my face already target for
abusers repeatedly
to fisticuffs and kicks I remember
staring at the floor and seeing my tears
drop into pools of blood coming from my
nose the louder I screamed the more they
flailed after about an hour the junior
officer returned you talk now yes
the guards loosened the wires and ropes
blood rushed back into my veins with
knife and pain
what airplane you fly I hesitated a
moment at the thought well they know the
airplane I'm flying and so ridiculous to
undergo such torture for information
they already have the f-4b
that part right there I mean when you
hesitate for a moment
and then you say to yourself okay these
guys shot me down in an f4 which crashed
into this paddy and they know exactly
what I was flying this is not make sense
for me to get this kind of abuse and
torture for something that they already
know and when you came to that
conclusion how did you did you was it
pretty we feeling comfortable with it in
your mind when you came closer look this
is stupid
no I was really never comfortable at all
in that I felt very guilty
I was very really was very remorseful
that I had not been as strong as I
wanted to be and in through the you know
the first several months of that
experience I uh I felt like I felt very
guilty about having given up you know
fighter pilots are not supposed to give
up you know just and the code of conduct
of course name rank serial number date
of birth I flew over this the enemy
thinking that I was strong enough and I
was good enough and and and suddenly I
was thrust into this situation and I
even wondered would I would I ever be
able to go back to my country can I face
my fellow fighter pilots that were
stronger you know and tougher and I
found out that that that feeling was
across the board every every powa I ever
ran into felt guilty and some guys even
considered suicide because they felt
like they could they could never live
with the guilt of having given up and it
was it was quite a revelation to me when
I finally made contact with another
prisoner and confessed to this guy I
remember that my first contact and I
said I said I need to confess something
to you and
when I tell you what I've done you may
not want to communicate with me you may
hate me and if our roles were reversed I
would probably hate you if you did what
I did because I assumed that I was the
only one that ever gave it and so he
said this is a Bob shoemaker vision he
said what would you do
plum I said well I I broke I tried to be
strong when I was nine broke and his
response and and we're talking on on the
end of a wire
we're tugging on a wire to communicate
with each other with this secret code
that I that he had just taught me he
said he'll everybody broke he said
there's not a man in this camp as strong
as he wanted to be said so get over
yourself you know and that wasn't it was
a great revelation in my mind you know
to know that I wasn't the only one that
they given in as you you continue this
and again I you might have felt like you
broke at this point but there's still
some unbelievable spirit that you show
and I'm going back to the book around
the courtyard in a nearby room my co-pi
copilot Gary Anderson was undergoing
about the same treatment as soon as I
heard him exploding obscenities I knew
he was near hey Gary you all right I
called the guards remedial on top
immediately on top kicking and striking
Gary heard me and yelled back it was
four years later that I came across a
pow2 had been to sell clothes to ours at
the time he said boy that was one of the
craziest things I ever heard you yelling
hey Gary are you all right bang crunch
thud fine how about you smack crash
cracked
yeah you eventually get they're going to
take you and kind of parade you in front
of the enemies people and going back to
the book the officer briefed me once
more I was to walk with my head down
until he gave me the command let people
see face the guards removed the cuffs
and I pumped my hands and torch my
shoulders to restore circulation the
guards carefully directed me to the door
removing the blindfold and warned me not
to look around
they then prodded me down the hallway
line with photographers and journalists
a group composed of Orientals and a few
Caucasians with the officer at my side I
walked out the building onto the patio
where a battery of motion cameras
started whirring the officer shouted to
me let people see face slowly and
deliberately I looked up staring blankly
into space bow deeply to the cameras and
lowered my head I was uneasy about this
entire charade feeling a combination of
resentment and embarrassment at being
featured as a sideshow attraction and
what I didn't know at the time was it
was Ho Chi Minh's birthday and so that
was part of the celebration was I was
being presented to the president of
their country as a birthday gift popping
out of a cake and and the good news was
that that I was I was in the media that
they were taking pictures of me and so
after a few months my family saw those
pictures right and and so that was the
good news about being shot down on the
19th of May so but that was a first
indication that people knew that you're
actually okay right or you were alive
maybe not okay the strong word didn't
mean to say okay you were alive the
picture that was taken and transferred
to my family has me with my eyes closed
and my face was pretty well swollen and
my little brother thought that I was
dead he thought that was a picture
deadman and so but uh but I think most
people you know thought yeah no he's
alive so you actually get so how'd you
get stabbed bayonetted so you were about
to fall or something actually I was I
was uh being prodded to walk faster by
these guys and I was I was hurting at
the time and I was injured from the from
the ejection and I wasn't able to walk
very fast that I was blindfolded as well
and so I hit a rut in the road and these
guards with her bayonet fixed behind me
stabbed me in the in the thigh and so
that was fact that was the worst wound
that I had and it festered for months
because I had no medical care and but I
never really knew if it was intentional
or it was accidental but that was uh
that was how I got that wound now you
get back in and they're going to give
you the give you the rules for the first
time that you're supposed to follow and
the guy reads into you and I'm just
going to probably read these rules
because uh I think they give a good
indication as to what you were facing
here we go back to the book you are the
blackest criminal that this country has
ever seen
but due to the lenient humane policy of
the Vietnamese people if you follow
regulations you live in peace regulation
number one criminals must give full and
complete answers to questions asked by
Vietnamese guard or officer number two
criminals must make no noise in room
number three criminals must keep room
clean and neat and must not mark room so
graciously given by Vietnamese people
number four
criminals must get up and go to bed at
sound of gong number five criminals must
get under bed when imperialist aggressor
bomb and strafe our sovereign country
number six criminals must say now cow
when they want ask anything number seven
criminals must go only in area that
guard orders when they go outside of
room
number eight criminals must bow to every
Vietnamese guards officers and people
number nine criminals must not bring
anything into room from outside number
ten criminals must not communicate with
or look at other criminals in any other
room or outside with minor variations
these were the rules for the next six
years big one was the communication they
didn't want you guys talking to each
other no they didn't and they is all
they possibly could do to keep us from
communicating but we got very clever we
had a lot of ways to communication now
you spend some time in solitary
confinement and here we go back to book
during this period of solitary
confinement I had much time to think
from the start I established a definite
schedule for personal reflection and
appraisal this included a two-hour
worship service in the morning and a
similar one in the evening I spent much
time praying talking informally with God
and recalling as many scriptures verses
and Bible stories as I could
I also revived the words and tunes to
songs from a Tennessee Ernie Ford album
that I'd enjoyed on the Kitty Hawk once
in a while I would start humming too
loudly and a guard would bang his rifle
against the door I spent more and more
time thinking about intangibles the
purpose for living Essex the
supernatural faith pride because the
tangibles which I had identified with
were no longer present my aircraft my
ship my personal possessions this was
the onset of a thorough re-examination
of my life often these intricate fought
processes ended in slumber one of the
interesting things that are really most
difficult to understand is how we had
nothing going on
I mean the average American has hundreds
of thousands of inputs every day colors
and sounds and smells and touch and all
these things and when you're in a little
prison cell especially if you're in
solitary confinement
you know you might you might hear a bird
you know and then that's delightful
that's a big deal
you know - you're a bird yeah and
nothing else so again the good news and
the bad news is your mind goes internal
and you start you have to you have to
create things on your own and so you
think about these intangible things and
you go back through your life and and
them and and you think about the things
that sustain life and why we are here
because there's nothing else to do did
you put some kind of structure around
your fault it seems like you people
might have a tendency just to let their
mind wander and maybe it wanders into
places they don't want it to wander into
no there was a lot of structure to it
and in fact one of the things I did was
to go back through my life to the very
first memory that I ever had at three
years old in Lecompton Kansas when my
grandmother came through and wanted
everybody to to go with her well and I
remember that date and then I went from
that to the day that I was shot down and
tried to remember every book I've ever
read every friend I've ever met every
girl I've ever dated every teacher books
movies experiences and and it took me
about as I recall maybe three months
working pretty hard on that that total
autobiography in my mind and after that
then I would continue to go back through
those individual days and try to
remember something else you know a
different color that I'd forgotten or a
different person that was in the room
and whenever I would when I would
discover something that I hadn't
discovered the first three months it was
like it was like meeting an old friend I
could think about that one person or
that one book or whatever you know for
an entire day
and so it was just it was a way of of
using that time and making the time go
by by working our minds did you somehow
catalogue the days in your mind oh yeah
it was a it was a chronology it was uh
and and most everybody did that a lot of
guys did it much better than I they
could tell you you know what was going
on
this day last year the year before in
the year before they you know they they
could remember everything had it all
packed away but yes it was very well
categorized you finally get some pair of
pants couple pairs of pants couple
shirts some underwear undershirt
toothbrush and some soap and you are
going to use it for the first time I
stripped and with my little drinking cup
doused myself of water lathered with my
new bar of soap and rinsed shedding a
2-week layer of grime and sweat then I
shaved using a double edge razor which
had no handle at last I was clean no
it's beard no leaking body I put on my
new clothes and wondered what
impressions I would now make on newly
captured POWs dressed in fresh a bloomin
I experienced a sublime physical and
mental catharsis even the pain of my
wounds seemed to wash away with the
filth fifteen minutes later I was back
in my cell Rhian spired to outlast any
Vietnamese endeavour to debase me the
door opened I waited for something to
happen and then in the doorway sauntered
in a tall man back hunched and forehead
deeply lined he studied me with
uncertain eyes an American another
American I rushed to the door as quickly
as I could and grasped his hand the hand
which was completely numb from
inadequate circulation at the elbows hi
I said I'm Charlie plum
so now you're linked up with another
American I am Kay Russell was shot down
the same day I was and so he and I were
he was my first roommate and and you
know I was I was in the same cell with a
lot of different guys and they moved us
around a lot about every six months
they'd move us around but they would
give us different roommates every few
months or take them all away and I was
in solitary confinement again and we
never really knew why but we assumed
that was tried to destroy any
fraternization with the guards and tried
to disrupt any unity within the
prisoners and so so that in fact
sometimes is a little bit difficult to
describe exactly what it was like
because we were in different camps in
different cells and you were different
guys for the entire six years you but
did you do you like it when you got a
new roommate cause it's like a new and
kind of explain it's like now you have a
bunch of stuff to talk about with this
person absolutely
absolutely it was it was glorious you
know find a because you know he of
course had all of the stories in he had
the movies that he could tell you about
and the things that he had learned and
that he could teach you so ya know it
was it was wonderful
now that would last for maybe a few
months until you're in other things then
it became almost like marriage you know
where you got those those periods of
time honeymoon period over yeah exactly
well in fact matter is you couldn't in
some of those cells you couldn't be more
than eight or ten feet away from a guy
24/7 for months and months and months at
a time and so little things start to bug
ya you know yeah and
not the least of which was what was our
toilet you know he the the toilet was a
two gallon bucket in the corner and lots
of times it was rusted out at the top no
lid and it was just quite a you know it
stunk to high heaven and a lot of the
cases and
and it was quite an irritant you guys
established a routine once you got in
there you know there's a whole chapter
in the book called routine and you're
waking up at 6:30 in the morning you're
doing prayer at that time you're at 7
o'clock you're you're practicing piano
which I like and I unpack the piano and
I was just from memory you had you ever
played piano before I hadn't I had not
now what I did know was that my span
from my thinking to my thumb was not was
I could span 9 notes on a piano and so I
laid out a keyboard on my board bed and
I knew where the Black Keys were and I
had played in in the band and I also
played guitar so a new little bit about
chords and scales and that kind of thing
and I thought well I've always wanted to
play the piano you know now's my chance
this piece of wood looks good to me yeah
this is a work and then at 8 o'clock
you're doing push-ups yep and sit-ups
and leg lifts and whatever else so
you're doing some some physical training
and you have school the school bell
rings at 9:30 a.m. and you guys are you
guys are learning and teaching each
other whatever you can possibly teach
each other whatever subject you were
good at you were going to teach we did
and it was serious stuff as a matter of
fact when we got home University of
Maryland gave us credit for what we had
you know that of courses we had taught
you know without books or paper or
powerpoints or instructors or professors
or anybody because we we were so intent
on using that time for something of
value and and in these guys
most of them smarter than I would go
back through their minds and recapture
all of the subjects that they had
learned one of the guy Jill Milligan I
was with him in the first few months I
guess and he taught a course on
a chemistry no no biology was biology
and I'd never taken a course in biology
and I was very interested and and his
course lasted about a week and that's
all he knew
but joke and I live with him for a while
but lay back on his rack about an hour a
day and just think about biology and
after being there for six years he his
course lasted six months and he knows
everything from protozoa some meta
Zola's and all of this just because that
was back there in his mind he was able
to recall that good to recall that and
it did deep enough and it is amazing you
know what what's back in there a near
human brain it's and we found that out
if you think about something long enough
and hard enough and again you don't have
these distractions of everyday life that
there's his awful lot stored back in
there yeah I had to bring this one up
too because you talked about how you
didn't have PowerPoint or whatever you
have pens and chalkboards and here you
go often in my dreams I must admit I
envisioned leaving the NOI Hilton going
home looking for and finding a brand new
yellow pencil and bringing it back to my
cell or I would dream of entering shops
containing nothing but rows and rows of
pencils I've never since taken a pencil
for granted that's you know we take so
much for granted I mean take so much for
granted okay and to think about that
right there and what what power a pencil
gives you the power to take notes the
power to create the power to draw the
power to write this incredible power
comes from this little thing that we
just gaff off like it's meaningless
that's right and for you to have that
much appreciation point that you would
dream about it at night Joe it's
incredible
ten o'clock you'd eat and what was the
floors of food I Jersey dries balls yeah
mostly rice that was the mainstay you'd
you know you get a small bowl of rice
twice a day once about ten o'clock once
about two o'clock in the afternoon and
then you had a 20
our stretch with nothing to eat
sometimes they give you a bowl of broth
and sometimes it would be some kind of
vegetable turnips or weeds of some kind
one we call sewer soup you couldn't
identify this stuff but I didn't eat it
you know there was not enough meat to
put in a coffee cap for a year you know
it really was no there was no meat of
any variety how much how much did you
weigh when you got out I waited by 140
when I came home but they fattened us up
before we came home and I figured most
of the time I was there about 115 pounds
did you ever was the hunger to the
hunger go away did you or you just
grinding hunger or did you just get used
to it it went away for the most part you
know after four or five months your
stomach sort of shrinks and when you
know that there's nothing else to eat
and so you know that they in all
fairness they gave us enough to keep us
alive and and and so that you know and
rice is a pretty perfect food
this is unpolished rice it wasn't the
Uncle Ben's that we have today and and
there's a lot there's there's protein in
there and there's nutrients in the rice
so that can't be mine yeah at dusk you
guys would have Showtime then people
would do what you're talking about
describing everything and every movie
they've ever seen every book they've
ever read and all that and you mentioned
in here that in the beginning of
confinement the movies that would get
described or created because people were
creating movies to write in their heads
yes yes it may went from PG to xxx
oversized
so did anybody come out and and execute
on some of these ideas that they had is
there anybody that came out and said
yeah I founded this movie or book oh
yeah yeah in fact several guys had great
plans when one guy was a farmer and he
had planned a pig farm that was that was
his whole thing and he did he came back
in the I live a guy by the name of Danny
Lynn who was an architecture student at
the University of Oklahoma and Dan and I
were together for a lot of years and he
dreamed about building this home and
that's all I thought about was building
this dream house and he had several own
things about this home that were very
peculiar one of them was that as the
sunlight would come through the top of
the wall around our prison the wall was
capped with barbed wire and electrical
wire and broken glass the glass was from
bottles it was various colors and in one
particular cell that then and I were in
the Sun would come through the glass a
colored glass and on to this this this
tank of water and then reflect up under
the eaves of our fat stuff and into
ourselves they had all these colors and
it was a beautiful thing you know it was
a kaleidoscope of colors and so he
designed the house and he figured this
whole thing out you know with it the
azimuth of the Sun and all this stuff
and I was going to do this but and he
would lay this out and he would draw on
the concrete floor with a piece of brick
and he was a great artist you know the
guy could design all this stuff and and
of course he wanted me to be involved in
this and then bore me to tears
Charlie what color do you think my
bathroom ought to be I don't know and I
don't know no no no Charlie green or
blue cream dan green okay so we Lee at
home in about a year
after I was living in Kansas and he was
in Oklahoma and he called me up Charlie
I got something to show you
and so I had a little airplane at the
time actually down to Norman Oklahoma
and he picked me up at the airport and
we drove outside again from about a
quarter of a mile away I saw this house
but I recognized but I'd never been in
Norman Oklahoma and I swear I could walk
in that house and touched any faucet or
any light switch you know on the whole
place because it was exactly as he had
decided the prison so I went to the
bathroom and it was blue he had gone
back you know he had built it from
building materials that he had
remembered and over the years that we
were there they changed and so there
were some of the was not available and
so he went to these old lumber yards and
he would find the building materials
that he had planned this house with and
used those to build his house but it
wasn't good work but yeah a lot of the
guys a lot of guys wanted to sail around
the world you know a lot of US Navy guys
and how to sail and and that was the big
fantasy was to take a sailing trip
around the world in two or three the
guys actually did that when they came
home awesome the guards some of the
guards were pretty sadistic and here we
go back through but probably the most
sadistic practice of all was a game
involving mice or puppies guards would
douse them with gasoline and set them on
fire and turn them loose to squeal and
scurry in search of relief from the heat
and the soldiers would chase them with
sticks playing polo with their live-fire
balls until the little animals blackened
and died so you get some serious SATA
sadists there it is doing evil things
and you say you didn't see anything
book magazine newspaper lyrics a song
written speech any billboard or anything
while you're there that was just on a
percent propaganda that's true you know
their music doesn't talk about love
except for love of Ho Chi Minh and love
their country and dedication to that
it's really incredible how they just
fill the minds of their people with this
propaganda and you know you tell
somebody long enough and loud enough and
they believe it and that's that was the
whole it was the whole country the one
point you got this propaganda newspaper
and it's the front page headline was
that there's been a revolution in
rice-planting technique and you were
thinking yourself oh man they must have
invented some big machine that can like
plan all the rice and now they don't
have to be out there on doing the manual
labor in the fields and here's the
actual article for four thousand years
the Vietnamese people have been laboring
sweating and toiling in the mud and
water of rice paddies we've discovered a
revolutionary method of planting rice
through extensive research we have found
that instead of grasping the rice
sprouts and planting them with the palm
of the hand facing downward is much more
efficient to plant the rice sprouts with
the palm of the hand facing upward so
there's there's the propaganda comin at
you and there's the advancement of the
you know them trying to tell the people
how we're moving forward in the earth
and that was another thing that
surprised me or it didn't surprise me
but how what they're they're
understanding you know they're they're
brainwashed and their understanding of
what American culture was like and when
you'd say well yeah I have a car and I
have an air conditioner to them that was
done believable because the only people
that could afford that in Vietnam were
which was a state itself true and they
assumed that if you had a car you could
carry pigs or chickens or something in
your car because that was the whole
purpose of any kind of transportation
was a whole something around and and
they you know they were really surprised
you could actually just get in the car
and go wherever you want to go and they
also thought that a third of Americans
were starving to death mm-hmm so that's
you know something think about us always
when you deal with these countries where
people are being indoctrinated and do
they're being fed information from the
state it's going to be it's going to be
lies
and you can't be surprised when they
believe something like that you just
have to say you didn't believe how do we
react Kim I went back to Vietnam first
time in 43 years I hadn't been back and
a lot of things had changed you know I
mean they still call themselves a
communist country but oh by the way
capitalism is alive and well but the
propaganda still exists there and in the
I took my family with me my wife and
three of our four kids and in the eleven
days that I was there I never met anyone
and I was at you know I was the embassy
I spoke to the students at the
University I spoke to cab drivers and
waitresses and anybody and they were
really really nice people and very very
nice to me
but nobody knew that Americans had been
tortured in the Vietnam War and in fact
it was just the opposite they all would
tell you that we got better treatment
than the soldiers did and better medical
care and the soldiers did and so and in
fact and in one of the one of the last
days I was there I ran into a lady in
the park
selling card postcards and she was
missing one leg and she was about my age
and so I sort of pieced this thing
together
and she said one of my postcard well
I'll buy a postcard but I want to hear
your story sit down on this park bench
no tell me your story and she did I said
how did you lose your leg she said
linebacker - linebacker - was the code
name for the b-52 bombings that ended
the war in night in the Christmas of
1972 at but it was a secret code name
you know and for her to just to say it
was issued she didn't call an air raid
or a bomb or anything else she's called
him linebacker - it was art you know
that was a pilot jargon not her jargon
and and I said what what what was the
date she said 24 December 1972 so I knew
that she wasn't lying to me
she said b-52 oh yeah well so we talked
for maybe thirty minutes on that park
bench and she spoke very good English
and and at one point I said to her you
speak excellent English you could be an
interpreter you could be a guide
why are you out here making a living
selling postcards in a park she said oh
my my country would never give me a
permit because I have an invalid and man
what a country and and then I said well
do you know about the museum's oh yeah I
know all about the museums and the Hanoi
Hilton Museum see they made a museum out
of my old prison camp and only Hilton is
now a museum and I said well how are the
prisoners treated at the museum all they
were treated great they had great food
they played volleyball they had ping
pong I said how do you know this she
said Oh documentaries the government
shows us documentaries and so she
finally figured out that I was about her
age and she said were you a pilot
I said yeah as a pilot she said b-52 I
said no I flew that for phantoms oh so
were you flying on the 24th of December
1972 I didn't know I was right here with
you I was in the Hanoi Hilton and I was
being tortured she said no that's
impossible
that can't possibly be true I could not
convince this lady that I would or
anybody else mMmmm so the propaganda is
alive and well they continued to tell
the people the lies and and the folks
have no way of figuring it out you know
it's another thing that that you point
out in the book on that culture or that
that system of government back to the
book the Vietnamese rarely exerted
themselves why should they if they were
going to get a meal at all
they'd eat regardless of whether they
were
for it or not they didn't worry they
didn't have to the state was responsible
for their welfare as well as their
guidance even the upkeep of state
property was not been a problem so good
for a scary thing when it really is when
you know when folks are indoctrinated to
that level and but it's so prevalent you
know and and they tried to do the same
thing with us nearly they tried to
brainwash us and it was more importantly
you were kind of worried about that too
in the beginning right i q-- follows it
was something you needed to be concerned
about and then you saw the ridiculous
all that yeah yeah and you know they
they they used a lot of the russian
military equipment but they never
invited the russians in to try to
brainwash us and we felt very very happy
about that because they're brainwashing
techniques were so silly and you know
they would tell us this unbelievable
things that that we laughed at where you
thought the russians would do a better
job oh yeah oh yeah i'm sure they would
have but more important than the rice we
ate of the water we drink and every
prison cell i was in the first thing
they put in there was a speaker and you
know lots lots of a prison camps didn't
have any electricity at all but they had
speakers and they were put well above
our reach so we couldn't turn him off or
adjust the volume and several times a
day they would come on with propaganda
and telling us you know how bad we were
now terrible our country was now
wonderful they were and and in you know
it was pretty easy to turn these guys
off you know just to ignore the the
broadcast but it was also very
concerning you know to see that that's
the way they so Andy indoctrinate their
own people horrible you you talked about
a little bit early you talked about the
communication and and what that was all
about and you had this left the first
time you were in your cell you hear a
little scraping and eventually you go
over and it's a
the wire and eventually note comes
through it and here we go back to the
book it had a piece of toilet paper tied
to it I unfolded it and found these
words memorize code eat note the code
was easier to memorize then the note was
to eat but I did both i rechecked the
door sat back down on the honey bucket
and tugged on the wire the code was a
series of tugs which represented letters
the alphabet and it's it's basically a
5x5 code ABCD efg and that is how you
guys communicated and that had to be how
long does it take to have a conversation
with that code because you give you no
one to trust to go down and then one two
three tugs to go across how long does it
take away these conversations Martha
taking a long dive well that's true but
that was the beauty of it because that's
all we had was time and that was a very
good way of wiling away the hours
tugging on the wires
tapping on walls and or or sneezing and
wheezing it we had all kinds of ways to
communicate and and we took great pride
in our communication effort and the
sneezing resistor that just was it more
sky how does sneezing and wheezing work
often it was the same kind of thing you
know it was all based around this five
by five matrix of the alphabet occur and
so a coffee would would be one a sneeze
would be two a wheeze would be three on
and so forth so that so that two sounds
would equal a letter and we use this in
a lot of different ways if a guy was
outside chopping wood for a fire for
instance and he would chop in this code
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop chop and it was
what we caught we called it a radio
station because everybody can hear it
and and so if a new guy came into the
camp and and we knew who the president
was you know lots of we did we had no
information on or knew who won the World
Series for instance why it was really
big deal you know
Aaron and chopped wood in a radio
station until the entire camp who was
the president is it yes did the guards
ever catch on to that 5x5 code yes
occasionally and a couple guys were
tortured to reveal the code but they
could but they were it was really
interesting because they were so
uncoordinated that they couldn't
replicate the code and they'd on several
cases they tried to trick us and they
would empty out a cell and they would go
into that cell and try to tap on the
wall or tug on the wire in the code and
we knew immediately you know that it
wasn't an American and you guys would
get like I said is interesting you count
you you laid out two things that first
the Vietnamese were like pretty much
okay with stealing and so you wouldn't
get punished for stealing that bad but
the communication thing is what that is
what they would definitely punish use
our yep true yeah that uh I I mean
that's the same thing I mean when we
captured prisoners overseas we will
don't want to talk to each other we
separate them and you don't wanted to
talk to each other and at some point you
started getting letters even and
receiving letters and how did that
change the environment well first of all
we were just overjoyed to see that that
our that our families you know that my
wife was okay and and that they knew
that we were alive and so it was it was
a wonderful connection that we made now
we we call them letters but actually
they were postcards and in they were
highly edited it began with the
postcards were just blanked out and then
the Vietnamese decided that's not good
enough they actually would cut out
certain words and so you get a postcard
and six lines and maybe of the six lines
there might be fifteen words that were
just cut out with a pair of scissors so
that sometimes you really couldn't
figure it out
what they were trying to say but you
know that the fact that that was in the
handwriting of a loved one was was was
it was very comforting and yet those
bastards and I used that term very
specifically for this situation the Dear
John letters they'd leave those
completely I'm good to go and turn those
over yeah you know and I say bastards
for that - that kind of behavior from
bastards yeah they were quick to to tell
us that our wives had filed for divorce
or that you know our parents had died or
that second any bad news they were they
were very quick to promote yeah the
chain of command that you guys here you
are in this prison camp and you guys
all's you know you figured out you
realize we need to have a chain of
command and you put that structure into
place and when you did that did that cut
I mean it seems like it would have seems
like that gave you guys so much strength
as a group to get in the chain of
command to organize yourselves it seemed
like that gave you guys so much strength
and fortitude as you as you were there
it was absolutely our survival was our
chain of command what what you don't
know in reading my book because there
only happened two or three years ago a
study was done of all the combatants of
Vietnam of all the million and a half
people that were exposed to that war
30.6% had PTSD almost 1/3 of the
combatants in Vietnam post-traumatic
stress disorder of the prisoners of war
four percent of us at PTSD and it's
primarily the guys who were shot down
near the end of the war were only
prisoners for a few weeks or a month or
two and what we really believe this is
spelled out in another book called
lessons from the Hanoi Hilton which was
written about two years ago lessons from
the Hanoi Hilton explains that the
reason why we came back and her in such
great shape
is because of the unit that we had in
the leadership that we had in the prison
camps because of the 591 guys came home
and of the 591 and they thought we'd be
in baskets they that would be vegetables
they had our families briefed to
institutionalize us for the rest of our
lives that's what they thought was
coming home risk and what can you expect
from 591 guys we produced 17 generals
seven Admirals most of us retired is
senior grade military officers we have
doctors and lawyers and preachers and
teachers and bishops and judges with a
bunch of congressmen two United States
senators two ambassadors we have a vice
presidential candidate a presidential
candidate my old flight instructor John
McCain and they're telling us today were
it healthier mentally and physically
than if we hadn't been shot down and it
was primarily because of the leadership
the chain of command that we had over
there the unity that we found and the
purpose that that's what the leadership
in the prison camp did for us Jim
Stockdale was our senior SRO senior
residing officer in the prison camp for
a long time and he said we are no longer
victims of circumstance beyond our
control we are not on the defensive here
we are military men we are combatants
and we will pursue this war till our
last breath and so what he did what that
did was it gave us a reason to live a
reason to be a reason to unify and the
the way we fought the war from the
prison camp was to try to deny them any
propaganda because as you as you've
already said Jocko that this the
propaganda was the mainstay I mean it
was that was numero uno in their world
was was propagandizing and they felt
that that that they could use us to tell
the rest of the world how wonderful
communism was and how terrible
capitalism was and how they were right
we were wrong and so they would they
would force
guys to make tapes or write letters to
the anti-war element and you know
proclaim that the the wonderful nature
of communism and so our job was to
defend against this and and so we set up
all kinds of methods so that we would
deny them any propaganda or even in some
cases we would even go farther than to
not deny the propaganda we would use
their tools against them and that we
would tell the world that oh by the way
we are being tortured and oh by the way
you know this you know these guys aren't
attacking our neighbor in South Vietnam
and so so that was the big effort then
and you know I said this whole thing
just came out a few years ago that this
was the big reason that we did so well
and that we're so healthy mentally and
physically today was because we had this
chain of command and on top of that and
this is what I've really won the big
points I wanted to talk about today is
what you're just hitting on is that
people have this idea that the military
chain of command is this rigid structure
and that's why it survives and that's
what they but you guys were put into a
position that it was yes there's a
military chain of command just like I
had in the seagull teams and if you if
you think in the SEAL Teams that I was
the guy that was in charge and I was
barking the orders and everyone's fallen
everything I said just like no it wasn't
like that it's a much more collaborative
deal and you you and and this really
became clear one section the book here
I'm going to I'm going to read that what
you were doing with home and how
challenging this leadership position was
for the people that were more leading so
here we're going back to the book making
sure that everyone was on our team was
the first of many objectives
understanding the rules of the game was
the second it was assumed that all those
had a basic knowledge of the military
discipline and the code of conduct this
code a very general document was open to
many interpretations how we construe the
code often depended on the severity of
the situation
no longer could we pick up a telephone
and call the Pentagon for advice the
broad spectrum of the code divided the
men into at least two groups those who
were disciplinarians by nature and
interpreted the code strictly and those
who were liberal and rendered the code
loosely we called these two groups the
tough guys and the softies but this is
the key part right here
soft key was not derogatory the name
simply indicated a different approach to
the code tough guys who referred to the
line I will never surrender of my own
free will
sometimes flaunted their encouraged
ability and taunted the guards the
Vietnamese answered with torture and the
tough guys occasionally relinquished
more information than the softies who
never committed themselves regardless of
our attitudes we were all in the same
boat each of us had acquiesced to the
Vietnamese control to some extent
whether accepting cigarettes are bowing
to guards the line which separated the
tough guys from the softies was often
unclear the important thing was to
display unity regardless of our
individual philosophies we clearly
understood that the Vietnamese would
capitalize on any chinks they found in
our armor unity didn't evolve
automatically learning its value
acquired from us such introspection and
sacrifice how could a camp SRO appease
the softies if he interpreted the code
too strictly or if he was too lacks for
the tough guys he was in an untenable
position having little control over the
actions of men in other rooms
he had excessive responsibility but none
of the tools of authority no reduction
of salaries suspension of liberty
court-martial indeed most of the fellows
he had never seen his only Association
being a tap on the wall or a scribbled
message to meet this impractical setting
the SRO wielded gentle sticks of
diplomacy they knew we were not boots
meaning boot camp guys fresh out of boot
camp who
who asked how high at the command to
jump we were all trained leaders who
acted independently for the first few
years the SROs Authority was limited to
advise rather than orders realizing the
importance of unity we respected his
this advice as though it were an order
what if we refused an order on the basis
that it did not come from the commander
but rather from five men who interpreted
through an error ridden system
what if compliance to the order brought
certain torture we were very lone in
answering these questions once I
received an order plum request you
communicate with captain Abuk at all
costs what did the SRO mean by at all
costs it include being caught and put in
leg irons for months at a time so the
way that that is laid out
it reflects not just leadership in the
prison camp I'm here to tell you it
reflects leadership in every situation
because the minute that you as a leader
decide that you're just going to impose
your will on other people is where you
start to lose respect and people start
questioning what you're doing that's
very true and I think that the way that
this comes out and that probably is one
of the reasons why you know I didn't
know about the the facts that you just
told me about the only four percent
having PTSD I mean obviously rattled off
all the successful POWs that came out
with this horrible situation but that
openness that open mind as leaders and
and as subordinates to say look I'm
getting this advice right this is
so-called advice from the boss I respect
it I'm going to act on it not because I
have to but because I understand the
mission I understand why we're doing
this and therefore it's not something
that's being imposed on me it's
something that I am accepting and
pushing forward of my own accord
that's a huge difference it truly is I
but I must admit that when I first heard
about this I was taken aback and I'm
thinking you know this is really silly I
got some senior officer down in the in
cell of the cell block
he's putting more restrictions on me
that I already have you know hey what
what what's he gonna do so stay away my
liberty card throw you in the Brig
yeah I'm gonna break I'm there and and I
had to be convinced you know that this
was in our best interest but but it
truly was and obviously that's the
reason we came out as healthy as we did
was because we well you know you say
better the most discipline you know a
discipline brought about freedom and it
was kind of crazy because we were being
restricted even more and yet because of
the restriction we had unity which gave
us the freedom yeah yeah and then you
guys started taking the broad code of
conduct and and specifying it because
you guys had so much time and do these
things that you called plumbers right
and you didn't really know what the
establishment of work homes came from
but they were they were detailed tenets
of how you all were going to carry
yourself and he called them plums and
they were things like the order that
you're going to go home you know not
aiding the the Vietnamese and in
whitewashing the truths the resistance
how what level of resistance you were
going to give when you were when you
were interrogated how much resistance
you were going to give with and and res
com6
was just no military bearing and then
res con 1 was straight-up hunger strike
mm-hmm that was one of greatest displays
I think that really affected the enemy
was when they found out that when our
commanding officer of a camp could say
ok res con 3 no more bowing to the enemy
and if so throughout the camp in these
individual cells you know there might be
there might be 75 different cells and
suddenly at the stroke of 1 one button
you know nobody would bow to the guards
and it really frightened them to know
that we had that much control that much
unity
and it was a silly thing but it but it
really felt so good he thought that that
we had that we had some leverage here
and and the other thing was that how you
stayed you unified was by not accepting
favors and then you had just the
dichotomy and leadership right you've
got a balance between hey if I can
accept a favor and it's going to help us
and it's going to make me healthier it's
going to then I should probably do it
but then they put this then that the
commander the SRO would put a
restriction or a reasonable timeframe so
this was a classic example because I
already talked about how how how in love
you were with pencils at this point if
at some point you got a pencil somehow
you got it they gave you a pencil and
you know the word spread that you guys
had a pencil and the the report or the
the direction came back was okay you
have 30 days to get more pencils so
we're all equal or you got to give the
pencil back right and you didn't get any
more pencils and you had to give that
pencil back tip that's but that you can
see how when you how unified you are and
how but just like you said that shows
the the the guards and the camp leaders
hey we are unified that you can't break
us you can't give you can't give
somebody some special help and not give
it to everyone
yeah unbelievable now you started
talking about this a little earlier and
I had to get a little bit deeper on it
because I think it hits a perk message
right so he's talking on living with
somebody and how when you're living with
somebody and the furthest you can get
away from them is eight feet as long as
I feel like this would echo and worse
we'd argue live with this gathered sit
do this vodcast thing for success and
you start saying okay that's good what
what things start to grind on you and
irritate you so whether they were
exercise you get a guy that's going to
exercise while you're trying to sleep or
you get a guy that's Norse which if
you've ever dealt with somebody that
snores they can't help but they don't
even know that they sound like a
chainsaw in your room and you deal with
you might get roomed up with somebody
that snores every single night and the
worst thing about somebody that snores
is when you start thinking that it
bothers you
it
right the pacing pacing was another
thing that would you know I mean this
could get up and pacing and hey man just
sit down so all these things some POWs
ate rice a grain at a time a grain at a
time and you know I got all these little
um these little I guess these little
idiosyncrasies right and what you
eventually said was I'm gonna take those
idiosyncrasies that bothers me about you
and I'm gonna take the blame on myself
I shouldn't be bothered by this and I'm
the one that can't let it bother me and
that is a huge difference to what most
people do which is hey it's all about me
and if you're bothering me you need to
change and your all's attitude was no
you know what my attitudes you don't
need to change I need to change I need
to become more accepting of the way you
are that's a big deal that you can make
that transition in your life and you
much happier person
that's true and I'm still trying we all
and it's one of those things where it
really is a game changer because now in
you know it's extreme ownership right
Amaka blame everything on you for
annoying I'm gonna pick it up myself and
then sometimes you you'd have something
that really like maybe you couldn't
sleep and now you gotta talk to somebody
else and have have an indirect
conversation instead of saying eh echoes
really bothering me clicking his pen
over there it's it's gonna drive me
crazy to them maybe talk to him about
his pen etiquette and hasn't stopped
that he's not doing it today sir but
there was there was an episode where he
had the pen in his hand things got a
little bit fidgety yes and uh yeah I
didn't let it bother me you know what I
did brought him a new pen that didn't
have the clicker on it I took ownership
for that hey I should be ed you know in
today's world we have so many people
that are so offended by certain things
and it's the same sensible there is that
if you offend me that's really more my
problem than it is your problem
I'm the one that decides if you intend
me so I need to change my day what's
offensive yeah yeah one of the things in
you know where it's easy to sit and
laugh here a little bit about some of
the stuff but one of your chapters is
called insanity and I'm going to the
book here the first I knew of it was in
the fall of 1968 and I didn't understand
an old beat-up French ambulance Ram
rattled into the courtyard an American
wearing prison garb crawled out he
weaved like a robot with head down and
shoulders slumped it was odd guards
never allowed POWs to walk that way we
devil timed who was this man had he just
come from the hospital was he tortured
in the semi-consciousness or was he
faking when would we find out the man
was hallucinatory insisting that his
cellmates were communists pieced
together with limbs and heads of dead
Americans whose arm is that he asked is
that my pilot's arm how can you call me
speak such good English because this man
was wasting away it was necessary for
his cell mates to force-feed him the
hostile patient was still strong
requiring four or five men to constrain
him so that a bamboo stick could be
forced between his teeth another
prisoner mashed rice down his throat
when they finished he would gag himself
to regurgitate what he thought was
poison from the Communists spewing rice
all over the room he was entranced when
the Vietnamese entered the room he
refused to bow angered a guard scream
bow bow and whipped his fist across the
expressionless face the man continued to
stand the guards continued to beat him
unmercifully then you guys continued to
see this every six months or so we saw
our sick powr rad transported between
solitary confinement and the hospital we
felt helpless the only way we could
assist was with prayer after September
1970 we never saw him again
there's little more to that story that I
did not know when I wrote the book that
he had been a part of a of an experiment
than by a Cuban the Cuban came over to
the communist country and as near as we
could tell his sole purpose of being in
Vietnam was to establish the breaking
point of an American fighting man so
this guy that I was talking about the
book and I didn't didn't know his name
at the time I wrote the book Earl Coble
was actually tortured to insanity and
that's and that is why he was insane and
and so his roommates then he was very
belligerent and I mean he was another
leadership principle because you've got
a group of guys in that prison cell that
were being threatened and some of them
were had broken bones or lacerations
because this crazy man he goes on a
hunger strike it is going to kill
himself by not eating and they had to
decide whether or not they were going to
force-feed him and keep him alive and
bring him back to his belligerence or
let him die and so it was it was quite a
dilemma in the prison camp and quite a
dramatic time when that was happening
and and they did they force-feed him and
brought him back to health and then the
Vietnamese for a reason we never really
knew but possibly because they saw that
we had some control they didn't want us
to have that control they pulled him out
of that cell put him in solitary
confinement and and and then he died
after that but but it was a it was a
tragic event that a guy would be
tortured to the point of insanity and
that was the purpose of the torture
thanks it back rather you said you said
they were the purpose oh no purpose
purpose was thirteen point yet to find a
breaking point and they found it with us
with Coe Beale you have another chapter
we touched on this a little bit earlier
about faith
going back to books I will be dumb that
will be done it seemed presumptuous to
try to change God's will to make a deal
with the omnipotent if I promise to
devote my life to the ministry extreme
in exchange for freedom and failed to
follow through what then no trying to
bargain with God was unfitting from the
beginning I offer prayers of acceptance
I remembered the experience of seeing
the christ-like shadow in the green
knobby room and the comfort I felt in
that time of great need that day I asked
God for strength to endure whatever
hardship I might face and I prayed for
an not for her fidelity or success but
for tolerance courage and most of all
her happiness with or without me I
continued this daily prayer now this was
faith was not just yours but everyone
and here we go again showing some of the
power that you guys had as prisoners
back to the book thousands of Bibles had
been sent to us from church groups all
over the world but the Vietnamese gave
us none asking wasn't enough so we
decided to go on a hunger strike our
senior officer informed the Vietnamese
that we simply didn't want more food
until we could have a Bible an
uninterrupted worship they retaliated by
shutting off our drinking water after a
few days the Vietnamese were ready to
settle and so were we
they would give us a church service if
we abided by certain stipulations the
service would be held according to their
schedule no one could sing no one could
stand and everyone would adhere strictly
to camp regulations every word spoken in
the ceremony was to be written down for
the censors perusal after all the
restrictions we hadn't gained much but
at least the V had given an inch after a
few weeks later the V saw that our
services were not militant and
relaxed restrictions they permitted a
four man choir to sing to him most
important they gave us a Bible for two
days so you guys decided to hold the
line on that one we did and it wasn't
easy they an interesting thing back to
the leadership was the the guy who
promoted this was a very staunch
Christian guy the number two in command
was an atheist and and and really had no
great interest in having a Bible in the
cell and so when the number one guy told
the Vietnamese that we were going to go
on a hunger strike think it they all I'm
out of it they took him away so that the
number two guy the atheist was suddenly
in charge and it was interesting to
watch what was going to happen here and
it was very encouraging when the atheist
said continue the hunger strike and
we're going to get this Bible awesome
you talk about their perception of the
Vietnamese perception of religion in
general back to the book the large
majority of Vietnamese were not Catholic
however and when they discovered us in
prayer as they did only last year they
asked what what you derived from this
thing God we tried to explain that we
received strength comfort help and
promise of eternal life these concepts
were too difficult for them yet many
seemed interested and did not mock our
beliefs to the die-hard Vietnamese
communists this state was their God
their truth their way their light the
controlling body and the government
decreed infallible canons without fear
of correction whenever peasants asked
who is the state they were told that
they themselves were and that they had
control in making decisions each was
told that he was part of the omniscient
state he was as long as he didn't
interfere I consider my confinement in
prison to be spiritually beneficial I
was given an opportunity
that few men have the time to pause to
reflect and to establish priorities I
found that my previous value system was
unrealistic stripped of all my material
wealth
the only beacon I could home homed in on
was my faith in an unchanging God and
you also went very deep on Fox around
patriotism and here's your toast talking
about patriotism some POWs were super
Patriots feeling the United States could
do no wrong a few felt that we had made
a mistake and it was time for us to get
out with most of the prisoners I
accepted the fact that we were not
perfect but felt that we were fighting
for a worthy cause and should persevere
into the end and this is something I've
brought up on many occasions the fact of
how hard we when I fought in the war in
Iraq and we went through extreme
measures to try and protect the civilian
populace and the civilian infrastructure
and here's your comments on that back to
the book great efforts were made to
persevere the lives and property of
civilians pilots were threatened with
court-martial if they failed to pinpoint
accurate military targets even to the
extent that they would jeopardize their
own lives by swooping just above
treetops to preserve a peasant hut 50
yards from a SAM RadarScope the
Vietnamese capitalizing on this made
targets especially difficult by placing
their military equipment in the middle
of peasant Hamlet's or next to schools
in fact several anti-aircraft artillery
guns were stationed on hospital rooftops
and your thoughts about the involvement
here the most powerful free nation in
history could not idly watch the
communist world gobble up and dissolve
sovereign nations we had to play the
surgeon to excise the malignant disease
of mind-control
I don't condone war I think there are
few justifiable reasons for killing in
Vietnam war was a last-ditch effort of
international diplomacy it was difficult
to justify my six years of imprisonment
when politicians with expense paid trips
to Paris should have solved the problems
through negotiation in this case our
negotiations were at the end of their
rope the Communists didn't understand
anything but the big hammer when our
b-52s shattered her noise defenses with
thousands of bombs
the Vietnamese realized we meant
business in this thought here we faced
East once a week and pledged our
Allegiance we contrasted our Bill of
Rights and the Constitution to the
Communist Manifesto daily we saw how big
brother destroyed individuality we
compared our lot with that of the guards
while prisoners of war were behind bars
the Vietnamese were captives inside
their own bamboo borders we consider
ourselves more fortunate than they one
day we would leave ourselves
powerful statement and that's exactly
what we thought was that that they were
the prisoners weight and we weren't we
were always there always of the belief
that we would go home and they had to
stay there they think it's a way to stay
in their prison and we would eventually
be released and you were right during
the week of 21 to 28 January 1973 for
the first time treatment was actually
humane the Vietnamese set up a
volleyball net and allowed us to play or
to exercise they gave us books and
magazines from home we knew something
was happening so you guys started a
sense that it was and you and you talked
about this in the book I didn't go into
much but there was always some people
that were would you call the people that
would look at the amount of food you got
yes it is they would read the amount of
rice you'd be given as to some
foreseeing the future of how long do be
enough once you call them the book we
call the love I forgot like food it
karien yes like that
no gastronomy astronomers realized
astronomers yeah anyone that said oh
they gave us here rice we must be
getting ready to be released and here
that feeling it sounds like you know
once a year once once every 18 months oh
yeah oh yeah you're getting her out oh
yeah I know well of course the dependent
on the person but some of the guys were
so optimistic and and I was an optimist
you know I would think you know home in
fact when I was first shot down I
thought we'd had finally given him the
the big blow that we finally brought
them to their knees on the 19th of May
and in the first few days in prison I
thought you know this is really going to
be ironic because of the war's over and
I fly home and my squadron has to take
the ship home I will be there to greet
them when they come home that's a really
positive attitude right there that is
optimal for guys have to ride the ship
back I will be home before them
and that's like I was I've said this
before on the podcast I always when I'm
in a commercial aircraft flying I always
think if this thing blows up in the sky
I'm gonna live I'm gonna be that guy you
know of course I'm not going to get
getting it sure everyone else is gonna
die not me
and so finally here we go back to the
book the camp commander once again
called our group together about 180 of
us old-timers it was the first time that
all prisoners in the camp were gathered
in one place we lined up by buildings
and military formation and were called
to attention by our acting Wing
Commander lieutenant colonel norm Gattis
although Vietnamese officials did not
recognize our rank structure they said
nothing camp commander read an
announcement and the interpreter read
the translation it had been a long time
since I had heard English worded so
professionally when he finished and told
us that we could go on when commander
again called us to attention and
dismissed us with bowed heads with heads
bowed we walked quietly back to our
rooms we were stunned some had waited
for these words for over 8 and 1/2 years
the war was over we were going home
did that even feel real at that point
and your hopes up so many times it
really didn't and they tried to trick us
many times you know they would call us
at a scientist confession
we'll send you home and and so even when
it happened for real
hit it we couldn't believe it it wasn't
really until we finally got a board that
at c-141 and it took off the wheels in a
well and and we there was a little
little bit of a administrative situation
when it came time because you guys had
all knew that you're going to follow the
order that you were captain of the sick
and injured we're going to go first then
the enlisted guys were going to go and
then order of capture exactly and that
was part of the plumbs right ok that was
that was part of all of the rules that
had that that we were binding by and so
we were in we were numbered ok the
second date you guys got went on and
then it was our turn but by number of
the date of shoot down and they pulled
20 of us out that were out of order of
the shoot-down date and we made a big
deal of this and then they they told us
well Kissinger told us we that we almost
caused an international incident because
for whatever reason that we really never
knew for sure except that all 20 of us
had had some some disappointing feature
to our return and we never knew if that
was the reason or not but we're either
coming back to deaths in the family or
disease or divorce or that kind of thing
all 20 guys and so but we were out of
order and we did not know why we were
out of order and so we we told them we
weren't going home and they went back
and forth for almost a day that we
refused to go home and then finally uh
Colonel Gaddis just pulled you in and
said listen you guys are going home he
gave us the direct order
and then you get to the airport at the
airport the bus halted near pockmark
runways we actually did solemnly through
a crowd of people and by microphone we
were told to walk through our receiving
officer when our names were called as I
heard my name I stepped past the table
what Vietnamese and American
representatives marked off the exchange
I saluted your Colonel then another and
was escorted by an officer who was so
excited he could have he could say
nothing more than isn't it great it's so
nice to have you back we've all been
waiting for you isn't it great
I felt as though he'd previously
composed what he would say but in his
excitement his record stuck he was right
it was great
I walked up on the ramp of the c-141 and
saw the first Navy uniform the officer
inside that uniform grabbed me and
hugged me and told me his name I didn't
know him until he told me he was the
briefing officer on the Kittyhawk the
day I was shot down Garry Mauro and I
had once worked many hours together and
now we could do if we recall old times
as soon as I was in the airplane a nurse
kissed me and started the first of a
long chain of flashbulbs we were given
American cigarettes magazines that
information sheets telling us what to
expect a Clark Air Force Base the pilot
taxi down the runway pushed up push the
throttles and at the moment of liftoff
suddenly it hit us we were off North
Vietnamese soil we screamed above the
noise of the engines
minutes later we were soaring above the
gulf of tonkin and saw some of our ships
the commander of the seventh fleet sent
a message of welcome and Jim returned
the radio comm with a thankful
acknowledgment by nightfall we reached
the Philippines in Clark Air Force Base
as soon as the doors opened we could see
and hear the enthusiasm from what must
have been 5,000 people
banners and bands choral groups and
cheerleaders everyone seemed to be there
I walked down the ramp saluted a general
and then an admiral as I shook the
Admirals hand I was so overcome with
motion that I helped him so you hug the
ACMA that was embarrassing
I don't know why I did that you know it
was just odd maybe a steak a Sabbath a
dog for secular I would argument yeah I
got what it gives him bit on thank you
sir
yes sir you're allowed to hug the
Admiral when you come home after that no
that's tonight I could tell what you
wrote that you're sort of like oh I just
do exactly overcome with emotions and
then you start kind of the in-processing
thing and I'm not had to be when they
start handing you magazines and
cigarettes and food and all that you go
into that sub what in here or there just
how overwhelming is that that was
wonderful
it was joyful you know I was reading
through some Vietnam pow2 'try and I got
caught you know I was just looking for
background I want to learn more and you
know people express themselves in poetry
and I've got locked into probably a
dozen poems that was nothing but
different foods like like raspberry cake
and I just a steak in milk and chocolate
milk and every second cells I thought it
was just about food
my favorite was when I was Jerry coffee
wrote a poem it was called ode to a
weevil and the poem was little weevil in
my bread I think I just bit off your
head that was that all you do go back at
the end of the we've all kind of cool so
you guys you guys are you know that had
to be somewhat overwhelming but you know
like you said you guys you guys were
were in good relatively good mental
status at Waverly yeah amazing now as
you're going through the motions with
the doctors and the physical people and
the the the PAS and public affairs
people you're
you're saying hey um you know when I see
my wife what's up with my wife and no
one's really answering that question for
you and finally you get the chaplain and
you say going back to the book here I
looked up at him and said chaplain I
have a great deal of faith in you and I
want you to level with me so far I
haven't been able to read a straight
answer from anyone and I want to know
about my wife would you please be kind
enough to tell me what's going on and he
says back well Charlie there is a
problem with your wife
she is well but she has some misgivings
I'm not sure as to the extent but I'm
sure that everything is going to be
alright she's written me a letter but I
didn't want to open it I felt that you
should and you get the letter and it's
nothing crystal clear but the message is
clear enough that you know she's not
wanting to stay married to you anymore
and you call her the next day actually
called my my parents first okay back in
Kansas I tried to call her but it didn't
it didn't work in fact they were they
were very protective you know first of
all they thought they thought I might be
suicidal when I heard the news and so
they were very protective of me and I
they wouldn't they wouldn't let me call
home even the chaplain and the
psychiatrist and psychologist wouldn't
I'm called home even to your parents
even to my parents yeah they had this
plan of how they were going to explain
this to me I guess but they would let me
call I finally found a social worker in
the hospital you know hey I want to know
you got a telephone around here I I
found a phone and I and I called my
parents back in Kansas and they're the
ones that actually told me yeah I never
forget my mom's words she said I sounded
give tenure years of my life I did not
tell you this but she's engaged to be
married to another man
she's filed for divorce and judge
wouldn't give her a divorce you know
it's her the the justification was
abandonment you know she see her husband
that had man abandoned her and the judge
wasn't buying that and so but no that
was the first I knew was when my mother
told me that she had filed for divorce
you know I going back to the book here a
few days later so he talked to Anne but
then some of the stuff you say here's I
actually I just I just have to quote it
um back to book yet Anne had told me
that she wanted to remarry
I would not become an obstacle to her
happiness
I called her parents they seemed quite
unsettled about Anne's decision a few
days later I called Anne again and she
complained that many members in the news
media had been harassing her she said
she had often been misquoted and was the
victim of character assassination I then
talked personally to some of the
newspaper men and told them that I did
not want her to be maligned in any way
in fact I wanted them to say nothing at
all about my wife for the most part they
were receptive to my wishes I gave them
a quote which they could use if they
felt they had to the divorces or got a
role as is a regretable but inevitable
drifting apart after so many years by
this time my hope for reconciliation was
dead I was determined to take it on the
chin and roll with the punches well I
may be coming off as a white knight here
but it wasn't at all that way she I
really to this day believe that in many
ways the ladies had it worse than we did
you know and if the it's the families
back here you know the military guys
they're over there and I'm sure you've
seen this in your experience as well is
it we we believe in what we're doing
were dedicated we focused you know we're
over there having a high old time the
families back here don't have that and
especially my wife didn't know if I was
alive or dead from one day to the next
she went through the same years 24 to 30
that I did she was supposed to be
faithful to me and she was supposed to
you know believe that I've coming home
not knowing if I'd ever come home and if
I did what I still want to be married or
would I be a basket case and a burden to
her the rest of her life and the the
other part of this which was which I I
didn't know at the time of course but
she lost her support group you know they
had a big Wives Club that's the squadron
pilots all of our wives got together and
they would take pictures and send us
cookies and make tapes and all these
things it was a very close-knit group
the wives of the pilots well when I was
shot down or when anybody was killed or
captured that wife was sort of Samara
Lee shunned by the rest of the group and
not officially but just because they
didn't you know that they didn't want to
they didn't know what to say and they
didn't want to be associated with
somebody who had that problem you know
they didn't want they didn't want that
to affect their life so she lost her
support group she she went back to
Kansas went back to school there and
then when she fell in love with this
other guy she lost what support group
she had it at home because her parents
were upset my parents were upset I have
a brother ten years younger than I am
that that looks a lot like me and he was
of about the same age during this the
latter part of this experience that I
had been when went in and I met and he
would go over to mow her lawn in Kansas
and she would break out in hives serious
emergency room kind of hives just at the
sight of my little brother because he
looked like me and and so they finally
the doctors restricted him from ever
seeing her because it cost her so much
grief so it was tough on the ladies any
way you look at it and I saw that and I
felt that and I felt like I needed to do
whatever was necessary to give her a
little peace
well you might not think you came off
like a white knight but that's pretty
you know awesome treatment of someone
for sure well and a lot of people you
know didn't understand it then and even
don't understand it today and you know
some people want to blame her but by I
have no animosity no blame whatsoever
for what she did and it was I have other
people that will say well don't you wish
that she had known early on that she was
going to divorce you no way to know her
know her her the thoughts of her kept me
alive you know that was not me that was
my purpose was to go back and be with
her the fact that it didn't happen of
course is somewhat incidental but the
six years I was there it was certainly a
positive for me to think about her and
you wrap up the book with a chapter
called reflections which is just
phenomenal and you know looking back at
kind of what you learned there and we
hit some of the some of the parts of it
because there's so much that everybody
can can learn from this going here to
the book our closed society subsisted we
ate slept breathe we laughed and we
cried we were frustrated and we were
gratified we were embarrassed and we
were proud slowly almost imperceptibly
particular patterns of behavior edged
into our daily activities and came until
they became folkways there was nothing
unusual about a man pacing the floor for
hours like a caged tiger no one no
notice was given to the man lifting his
soup bowl and licking it spotless
there was no stigma and baring our souls
to one another we had our own mores and
sense of propriety our microcosm was a
petri dish containing its own strains
and culture although we had not been
hand-picked we were for the most part
out of the same mold that of the
professional officer and pilot we were
unique prisoners who acted differently
from those of Korea the world war two we
have been exposed to a different
selection process and a new era of
lifestyles gathered together in a
dubious fraternity of Hanoi skydivers we
were a group of cocky individuals we
knew we were the best stripped of
personal possessions of million-dollar
airplanes of rank and prestige we
suddenly found ourselves at the bottom
of a dark pit we could no longer look
outward our only alternative was to make
the best of what we had and when you
have so little and for you guys to take
that attitude then there's so many
people you know when I hear from people
all over the world that will reach out
to me and talk about the situation that
they're in a bad situation in a negative
situation and and you know it's hearing
from people like you that makes everyone
realize I need to make the best of what
I have you know I need to make the best
of the situation I'm in because if you
guys could do it anyone do you know it
again
and this sounds like grand high level
philosophy but it was it was almost a
survival technique you know it's almost
hey this is the way that we can make it
through this his is believing in in the
future and believing in ourselves and I
look back on that six years and it was
probably the most important six years of
my life because because I came through
the silly experience with with this kind
of this kind of discipline this kind of
thought process and hey it's not the
hand you're dealt it's the way you play
the hand you're dealt you may not have
four aces this round you know you may
have trashed
but if you play it right they can still
be a winning hand a little bit of talk
about you coming home back to the book
my first impressions of home were not
too encouraging newspapers and magazines
were devoted largely to the drug problem
permissiveness the energy crisis
abounding crime rate and eroding and
aroni and eroding family structures
I was worried worried from a selfish
viewpoint I'd sacrificed many years for
my country and I didn't want some young
whippersnappers destroying it
but I decided to give myself a one-year
moratorium before taking a firm stand on
any of my observations and I found that
the news media in particular had
exaggerated the negative I didn't have
my wallet stowed stolen nor did I see
opium dens or gang wars when I visited
schools and said I was pleasantly
surprised with student demeanour young
people freely asked questions
and showed a genuine concern for answers
to me they seem to have been unduly
criticised by an impatient adult society
rather than given been given wise
counsel they have more freedom and I
think they are generally capable of
handling those freedoms they are more
mature than their counterparts of my
generation they have to be to survive
and one of the reasons I call that
little section out is because guess what
we hear about the Millennials right now
we hear the same thing about the
Millennials and maybe just everyone
should give a little moratorium on
themselves I'm going to start imposing
more moratorium so myself I think that's
a great idea well as I start definitely
doing that self-imposed moratorium is it
you hear an ain't no meet with up you
know we work with a lot of businesses
and companies and people ask us about
you know we got these Millennials and
it's so hard to lead them and I say oh
why is that because they want to
understand why they're doing what
they're doing because they want to know
what the goal and purpose of their of
their job is that's nothing new
oh because they're because they want to
step up and run
I want that person working for me so
yeah put a little moratorium right back
to the book wall in prison I had a lot
of time to think the same question kept
popping in my mind what am I doing here
I'm 10,000 miles from home cooped up in
a communist prison camp unable to enjoy
all the wonderful freedoms I was sent
here to protect my first answer was
obvious I'm fighting for my country I'm
serving the United States of America I'd
learned in school that America was
purple mountain Majesties and amber
amber waves of grain that it was
Congress and the executive and the
Judiciary
these were self-evident but I had to get
more personal than that
America had to mean more it had to
relate to my own freedoms the product of
nearly 200 years of a pioneering spirit
my nation is a skinny kid who climbs on
his bike before dawn to sling newspapers
my country is a librarian who sits
behind glasses with pencil in her hair
and is quick to find answers to my
questions my homeland is a truck driver
who smiles down from his cab and signals
me through the intersection my America
is a personal friend and I am proud to
serve her and you go on to say that
there must be a thousand definitions for
freedom mine is simple freedom is the
ability to walk through the door it's
not the act of walking through that's
proof of freedom it's not going to
church or speaking one's mind or
demonstrating in the streets freedom is
the ability to choose whether to go to
church to step up on a soapbox to carry
placards now then I am released again I
move about at will I say what I wish I
criticize and take criticism I feel
freer now
than ever before because I know what
freedom is I appreciate those freedoms
because I was once denied them
is there anything is there anybody that
appreciates freedoms more than people
that have had those freedoms tonight
probably not
is there any way to transfer the
appreciation for those freedoms I mean
I'm doing my darn bit here you turn your
darkness and we're in the same business
you know I speak a couple of times a
week all over the country has since I
came home trying to impress this on
people but the truth is there's no way
that you or I can't put people in that
situation that we've been in and make
them feel the way they feel there's no
way I could deny a person a freedom that
I did corporate workshops as you do and
and I'll put it I'll put a person in a
room by themselves with nothing there
for 15 minutes and they you're crazy
you know if you take their phone yeah I
got that down to five years active
exactly yeah they're going not and so
there's very little well I should say
this way it's difficult to make that
transfer to make a person to appreciate
freedom when they've never lost theirs
and all I can do is tell the story and I
appreciate your helping me tell the
story
I'm trying over here I'm going to you
know occasionally I just have to go that
a little bit of the distance on some
stuff that I've been there as one of
those situations that to wrap up because
I think this is just such an important
message for me for everybody back to the
book I'm often asked how did you do it
commander how could you take six years
of filth brutality and loneliness I
could have never done it my answer is of
course you could as a matter of fact you
rub elbows each day with people who have
done it we weren't the only prisoners
millions of Americans have experienced
the
nickels of the body or shackles of the
mind they've been bound by unfortunate
external circumstances automobile
accidents disease natural disaster
paralyzing grief from the loss of a
loved one they've suffered deprivation
and humiliation once a victim of
misfortune many become too insecure to
open doors instead they allow themselves
to wallow in despair they become
alcoholics drug addicts unfaithful wives
or husbands unruly children inability to
face personal responsibility is often
hidden and seemingly innocent pastimes
golf poker television sleep these
diversions spawn intense feeling of
guilt and worthlessness and some victims
ultimately isolate themselves and become
despondent a few commits suicide
I had ample opportunity to dam society
and curse my fate but what good would
that have done to be sure the Vietnamese
would not have released me simply
because I felt sorry for myself on the
contrary they used every available means
to make that happen a despondent
prisoner was a prime candidate for
communist indoctrination my secret for
enduring six years of hell is really not
a secret at all first and foremost I had
faith in God knowing that his will would
be done I never doubted that I could
persevere
I simply trusted God's promise to answer
my prayers I also love my country its
people and its freedoms I realized that
because of the human element the stakes
could be made
but in growing up I had discerned that
most of the people in this great land or
honorable honorable and compassionate
second I had self-discipline it would
have been easier to avoid Church torture
by succumbing to North Vietnamese
interrogation it would have been easier
to assume helplessness by blaming an
evil world
I could have rationalized myself into
mental and physical paralysis however
strict self obedience gave me the
ability to persevere finally I had pride
I was proud to know an inocent God I was
proud of my country and its heritage I
was proud of my family
I was proud of myself faith disciplined
pride each of these nurtured the others
combined they allowed me to endure I
have joined the ranks of millions of
Americans who have applied heroic
principles in overcoming hardships every
day a disabled veteran steps away from
his wheelchair every day a life has
resumed after a death in the family
friendships erased loneliness addicts
throw away the crutch of alcohol or
drugs or obsessions every day someone
discovers how to love life no matter
what the obstacle everyday someone sees
the light at the end of the tunnel these
ordinary Americans are not held in
esteem as heroes yet they suffered grave
misfortune and have recovered just as I
so you see I'm no hero
and I think it's that very humility sir
that makes you a hero because you are
certainly a hero to me and certainly a
hero to this great nation well thank you
thank you for that and I am so those
bouquets right back at you you're one of
my heroes
I don't accept sir not at all you know
as you look at other people's struggle
with all the things that you mentioned
the drugs the alcohol the obsession
depression after the loss of a loved one
how can people find the faith the
discipline the pride that you talk about
what do you think is that kernel that
starting point that allows those things
to grow in someone's mind so that they
can overcome these kind of challenges I
think the first seed that you have to
plant and nurture in your mind is that
you still have the choice that you still
are in control because I think so many
people that get bogged down with these
challenges we're talking about assume
that there's no way out that it's
somebody else's problem or somebody else
has to to affect their lives and they
feel like they have no control over the
outcome and so I think that's the
beginning part of it is that each of us
makes decisions every day that control
our destiny and it truly is not the
things around us it's it's our it's our
approach to the things around us it's
our definition of the things around us
it's our willingness to accept a
challenge and make choices about the
things around us and so if you can if
you can nurture that if you can believe
that yes I have control of my life I am
I am the match
my fate I'm the captain of my soul
and if you can really believe that then
the rest is just a matter of the
discipline it takes to work through you
know it's interesting I was talking you
know was talking your son Alex and we
were we were talking about how you know
as he was growing up and he was hearing
your sort of philosophy of life in the
world and and when he heard me on on the
podcast and he started saying wait a
second um I've heard this kind of stuff
before and and we were talking about how
you know I've kind of said that now that
you know there's some I hate to go so
far as to say universal truths but
there's certainly some things in human
nature and human life that are very
similar across the board and when you
take people and you put them through
this this this crazy thing of life and
you provide them with some similar
challenges they're going to come to very
similar conclusions and and and from
what you just said you know there's two
things that you said that I say all the
time and number one this perspective of
you know what's that initial spark to
say hey I can take discipline I can take
pride the first thing in my mind you got
to say is like okay these problems that
are happening I can take ownership of
what I can do I can take ownership of my
problems I can't blame this guy can't
blame that guy I gotta take ownership of
them and that's the first thing and then
the other piece that you said that I say
all the time is decisions to make you
got little decisions to make and if you
can make that right decision if you can
do the right thing at that moment in
time it's not going to change your life
that one decision won't change your life
but then you're going to three minutes
later thirty seconds later an hour later
kind of make another decision and can
you hold the line and get yourself
pointed in the right direction and can
you have the discipline to do that can
you have the faith in yourself that
you're going to make that happen
and can you have the pride and you know
what dick winners talked about that too
of a lost lost podcast you know dick
winners from the first of 5:06 Band of
Brothers but one of the big things that
he was concerned about with his men was
if the if you still saw them begin to
lose
pride and how if I don't care what
echoes thanks to me if I come in here
I'm not ready for this podcast and he's
gonna look at me like this Jacque was
just letting it slide and all of a
sudden if I don't care anymore I don't
care anymore
now I'm not preparing now I'm not
getting ready and and then you take
someone in combat and they start to lose
pride and Nelson they say I don't care
who sees me acting the wrong way who
sees me slacking off on watch who sees
me not cleaning my weapon if I don't
care about that anymore that's the
beginning of that downward spiral and
pride is one of those things that you
have to be careful of because just like
any other dichotomy that we have as
human beings yes you can get so much
pride that you no longer think you can
do anything wrong and we know where that
leads that's right and you can have not
enough pride to keep yourself on the
right path right amazing stuff
echo did you have any questions just
wondering yeah well this one part I kind
of wanted to reflect on that I thought
was pretty important even on a smaller I
liked the part where you were
regarding the guards as in their own
prison you know but you almost like I
said that they had it worse than you did
so here this one time my wife told me
the story with shoes and check-out line
you know in the store yeah a lot of
stuff happens to protect out like a lot
of things happen with the grocery store
yeah I draw a lot of lessons a lot a
lesson so she was she found herself in
the Express line but she had more than
the 15 items no and the guy behind her
started he was tripping the whole time
no so she's been she's trying to hurry
up and he's like you you know you know
what he called out talking like talking
to the person next to him about my life
so after the whole ordeal it was kind of
like a scene you know so my wife
afterwards was like oh I hope you have a
nice day you know I could you know she
left well did she say it earnestly yeah
that didn't sound real earnest yeah well
and I don't I don't realize I don't know
think that she probably yeah she was
probably salty for sure but at the end
of the day it's kind of like hey I hope
you have a nice day and she so she told
me that
and she was like but you know what a big
part of me was like he has to go home
with himself you know and I get to come
home and be cool and have all my girls
you know all this done because like dang
that's a good way to look at it cuz you
have to go home he's probably pissed
yeah for the day and you know she used
to go home with 17 grocery items - yeah
wouldn't leave me right - oh yeah one
question you know when you got arrested
when you bought that scooter yeah you
figure about this because I've been in
this experience because you get the
scooter a you pack your friend yeah
right and then the tops a co-op you that
happened to us all the time why did they
arrest you those I mean is it like hey
you guys can't do that you're going to
jail
well it was rather unusual I think for
these cops to see two little guys do you
know we were 13 and 14 years old and we
weren't very big to begin with and the
motor scooter was a bigger than we were
and it's in the middle of night and
we're quick okay I I think they they
felt they felt like it was something
suspicious yeah yeah you took it you're
so lucky
well alright echo what sir do you
everything else on that on that right
there no okay no no no further details
on the scooter rides medic I forget that
great I will drop that this way echo
this um you know do you think that you
could maybe tell us how to support the
podcast sure of course I can't that's
what I'm here for one of the many
reasons so um if you want to support
this podcast many ways first way you can
support yourself I said it before the
fit again on it supplements right you're
doing physical stuff supplements that
gets you through I'm not gonna spend too
much time on it I want to I won't I'm
gonna recommend the krill oil and
Istanbul that's it so just sir I'm not
letting this annoy me I'm just gonna I'm
just like okay with it it's my problem I
don't want to listen him talk that's my
problem he has the right you speak for
long hours about you know this stuff but
here's the thing the part like it's that
you were to get annoyed the only reason
you didn't get annoyed is because you
know this stuff well some people they
don't know there's all those people or
maybe they want to hang out on your
every word but the good thing about on
it you know that's a good stuff because
supplements can be kind of junk
sometimes but this 100% these is a good
stuff and there's stuff for everything
in life everything we only talked about
the krill oil some other stuff but you
go on their protein wellness to even
like digest everything they got on there
on accom that's where you get it if you
want 10% off honeycomb / choco another
way before you do your amazon shopping
click through jaakko podcast comm to do
your amazon shopping and then you know
do your shopping is the normal good way
to support small action big reaction
takes about three seconds something like
that before
either way do that that's a good way
also subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't already
that's itunes stitcher google play and
other podcasting platforms subscribe on
youtube put some excerpts on there Tamar
has one that's a good a good one yeah
minutes is your just so you know you're
getting outside the boundaries ocean it
of an excerpt man I'm listening to it
I'm like we don't want around it right
there but I'm like oh wait wait that
kind of helped it you know a little I
was it the good one this 12 minutes long
emotional angry getting angry or getting
okay controlling your spice when your
emotion emotion I'm going to need these
trifle your emotion yes exactly right
when it's level 2 or lower on the
Richter scale of emotions
you can't behavior your emotions your
behavior can be basement anyway look at
that little excerpt put Mars reducible
to Jacko podcast youtube subscribe to
that that's what you see after ok you
know the doctor cam YouTube genius like
just like a channel it's a you tunic
channel anyone who knows what YouTube's
gonna know this I think I know a little
dinette version but I didn't quite put
all that together it's all good girl I
think you're already subscribed you get
the notification you're all handsome
you're all good you're all good
100%
also chakras store called Jocko store
Jocko store calm there's some good stuff
on their t-shirts if you like tee shirts
we wear t-shirts right I know I do some
women's stuff on their shirts patches
rash guards hoodies new rash guard out
maybe maybe maybe not you got to look
jockle store calm get some good stuff
though we've got some kid stuff two of
them yeah that's right you're wearing
with us some more years or you're done
stuff yeah you two both look although
we're hitting me up for your kid
t-shirts and and then immediately people
said we want them for adults too so we
made room for kids but then adults said
we want them now we got warrior kids
because you can you be a 45 year old
warrior kid I think I am yes sir I'm in
the game that's warrior kid yeah and if
you didn't I mean you're gonna obviously
talk about the word kid where the word
kid look but man when you read that look
you're like dang I wish I would have
read this whether it be when I'm a kid I
wish I would've read it up one day
before I read it that day that's how
much you mission would have known all
this stuff because it's been real basic
there so deep man uncle Jake's got some
info layers many layers upon layers very
people now identifying layers on Twitter
by the way which is a pretty yeah
there's been some really good
identification of layers there's some
layers in that book yeah they're gonna
get deeper - yeah man it's good so yes
you know he asked back to the store
chuckle store come you can see what's on
there this cool stuff and if you want to
support get something you know also
psychological warfare if you know what
that is which I know you already do but
in the small event that you don't it is
in album on iTunes with tracks and
Amazon music with tracks not music
tracks spoken word tracks technically as
what's called a spoken word number one
by the way yeah still still number one I
mean for good reason it does look yeah I
did put together psychological warfare 2
and I got some really good suggestions
from everyone yeah on things that need
where we need help yeah group so if you
got those hit us up on Twitter to give
suggestions for
or psychological warfare two tracks in
what you need areas where we need help
we all need help yeah I got some some
like me Felicia lavender question yeah
they're all my personal one yeah I think
I got 48 now oh yeah if you don't know
what that is it's like it's an album you
get it you have you know in your journey
of what getting after in your getting
after it journey pretty you're not
strong the whole time you just not get a
moment most of us aren't getting that
moment's a weakness but guess what in
those moments of weakness you listen to
the designated track if you're having a
weak moment of weakness when you're
trying to wake up at 4:30 come under
this that's early 4:30 every day yeah
the day is probably going to come where
you're like you know what I'm gonna hit
the snooze guess what listen to get up
and get off get up and get after it just
like two or three of those two and I
guarantee you won't hit the snooze
you'll get up you'll get after it anyway
that's that's what I think 100%
certainty anyway again called
psychological warfare on iTunes and I'm
done music and some other places we buy
into the music they're on all all of
them in there yeah good and also by the
way the book that we reviewed today with
Captain poem it's available on Charlie
plum comm CH AR l IE PL u MV comm that's
where you can get it it's called I'm no
hero that's right and also you can get
some jock a white tee on there if you
need to drink liquid in your life you
might as well drink a liquid that's
going to make you smarter and stronger
faster and a more dynamic human being
there's only one drink that does that
and that's chocolate tea by the way it's
one hundred and forty seven percent
double wine possible crude and true and
tested in a laboratory with people
wearing a white outfit so you know we're
good to go way to warrior kid and this
is the book right there that's going to
hit your kids from another angle you
know and it is going to get them to
understand some things like hard work
discipline honor
physical training mental training
studying no one think Jocko was going to
write a book of teach me how to study
they didn't take that did deco
nobody truth they didn't think that no
then you see my college great okay so
you learn how to study or not get
stronger in the book where the warrior
kid get it for your kids and you know
what you're gonna read it first and then
you're gonna get a copy for yourself
where the warrior kid get that can I say
something yeah once a part yeah sure we
have another four hours space on the
recorder
there's a part when he sees small
progress I think he's after one pull-up
mm-hmm and he's like yeah oh yeah fired
up at the part when he said he scolded
them small mild scolding for celebrating
too early yeah or too much too early
Jake said hey take it easy there yeah
good and but then he said now come over
here give me a high five ain't get back
to work when you let him celebrate a
little bit good man my Uncle Jake is a
good man I asked it and put it out to a
right also you can pre-order the book
disappoint equals freedom Field Manual
which explains to you how to get after
it so get after it and order the book of
course extreme ownership this is for
your leadership principles tested just
in combat testing the business world
they're there for you to read learn lead
win and if you need more than that from
the book if you need more than the book
in the podcast for your business or your
team Peschel on front s L'Enfant comm
you can email at info on national on
front comm leadership and management
consulting training also the muster
number three number three Austin Texas
July 13th and 14th Omni Barton Creek
Resort I'm not going to say spot anymore
not going to the spot Donna you know I'm
gonna have that a to shut down while
we're there good to be no Spa going on
so come down July 13th and 14th to join
us in the
of world domination that's the goal and
if you can't make Texas you can come to
San Diego September 14th and 15th back
in SD for number 4 and in the meantime
while you're waiting for that if you
have questions or comments for us you
can get us on the interwebs now first of
all
speaking of Millennials captain plum sir
you are all up in the technology here
well you are on twitter at captain plum
right right facebook facebook what's
that at LinkedIn yeah same thing
captain plum just a social media junkie
is what I'm here my kids keep me on it
and and you also you mentioned quickly
while we were talking that you do
speaking engagements and all that
where's the best place to contact you
for those type of events or consulting
all on my website Charlie calm calm it's
all it's all there
awesome so and that's where they can
find you
as far as echo and myself we are also
cruising on the interwebs on Instagram
on Twitter echo is a deco Charles I am
at Jocko willing and we are also in a
Facebook so one can check that one as
well
echo you got anything else for us today
I don't thank you so much yeah
Sharleen honor and sir do you have
anything any other closing thoughts you
want to add well I want to tell you
about the rest of the story so as people
might be interested in knowing that my
ex-wife married the guy she was engaged
to and they're they've been living
happily for the last forty three years i
remarried a wonderful lady he had four
kids two grandkids and one on the way my
daughter is married to a marine and
they're pregnant with her first child
should be do in fact any day now
Centrify daughter have a wonderful wife
supports me and since it puts up with me
and and and I'm living the dream I
really am I don't know how I could be
happier in my life I could not write a
story that would bring more fulfillment
to me personally than what I already
live I still fly airplanes I have two
airplanes I have a home and a hangar as
well my mancave and it's just it's it's
a delight to be alive and I appreciate
you for helping me tell my story because
I believe it's an important story now
not everybody is going to be a prisoner
of war in fact I hope I hope and pray
none of the people listening to this
podcast will ever be in that 8-foot cell
but I was in but we all get into our own
little prisons and and we can be I'm
convinced just as confined in our little
eight-inch box as I was in an 8-foot
prison cell and so if if those
challenges are the same then the
solution is the same the solution to the
prisons that we find ourselves in
another self discipline that it takes
the believing that yes I am a control on
my my own life I am a captain of my soul
and and that I do as I do make a
difference so you put all those things
together and and you can't in fact live
a life with the hand that you're dealt I
won't even try and make any additional
points on that other than to say when
you have a hanger with two planes in it
for your man cave you win the man cave
contest absolutely that's unbelievable
and sir obviously I I can't thank you
enough for coming on the podcast for
writing the book for sharing the
knowledge that you paid so dearly to
acquire and more important than all that
I can't thank you enough for your
service and your sacrifice
for six years for us and for this great
nation and you dedicate your book very
simply to the families of those brave
men who will never return and for those
families and for those brave men we will
live and we will try to live as you have
exemplified with faith and pride and
discipline to overcome whatever
hardships we might face and whatever
obstacles might be in our path and
through those adversities discover every
day how to love this life so until next
time this is Captain Charlie plumb and
echo and Jocko Oh